before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys we have just started a
facebook page and a twitch page so go
give it a follow we also have a new
recruiter eddie he is going to be
talking to you guys if you want to come
on the show so if you're in london dm
eddie his link is in the description
on top of that go follow my instagram
too it's just dot pearly things and sign
up for our memberships to be involved in
the second half of the show
so today i have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and where you are from starting with you
my name's lydia i am 28 i am in a
relationship
and i'm from london
my name is susie i am 28 i'm single and
i'm from london
um my name is maddie i'm 32 i'm in a
relationship with about five guys
but how does that work they don't know
each other are they wait i got questions
are they friends
is it like mute do they know
i was i'm i'm slightly joking oh okay
okay it was more like two two okay
sorry it's more like two okay okay
um what was the other thing did i miss
something i just wanted to know how that
worked i just i i just had questions
i've never done one of those so i called
them my boyfriends but we haven't really
had the chat so oh okay okay you know
what i mean okay i got you
so play in the field a little bit a
little bit a little bit
and then where you're from i don't know
so i live in west hampstead but
originally from surrey okay
hello i'm chantelle i'm 36 i am single
and i'm from london
who's lots of know me right now i'm
eddie 28 single pringle ready to mingle
from london
okay so today's topic is has feminism
destroyed marriage forever
so my question to start is do you
consider yourself a feminist and what
does feminism mean to you so you could
start
um i don't consider myself a feminism
feminist feminist
but i believe in equal opportunities i
don't really know what femi i think
feminism has um been taken a bit too
overboard as of lately that's why i
don't consider myself one
um what it means i don't even know at
this point i wouldn't classify myself as
a feminist as well um
but the definition of feminism for me
is
like lydia said equal opportunity and
equals respect
um so i would consider myself a feminist
um my personal opinion on feminism as a
movement and as an ideology are two
different things okay so i think the
movement is bad has become bad certainly
and also it was very rooted in like
white supremacy if you look back in it
you know what i mean a lot of the
feminist movements was white women
walking before you know the black well
it started with men right well it
started with men did it in 18 seneca
falls in new york it was the majority
that actually went to the first feminist
movement was men really
okay well that's very interesting but
i'm talking about the suffragettes so
obviously this may not have been the
first thing but
at that time you know it was
it was widely a sort of speaking to your
mic it was widely a sort of um
like mainly sort of white
movement right
i think anyway but well from what i've
read yeah uh but
just in general i i believe in the
ideology i don't necessarily
so eat the movement okay so you think
the movement may have gone too far
i think a lot of movements go too far
okay yeah but you back the ideology as
and you think men and women should be
equal no no no okay cool i think we
should have equal opportunity okay i
think that we should actually um
understand that we're very different uh
but that's what makes us um balanced
okay that's what we should be right um
but also i think that um you know
there's equity that should be involved
there as well like for example you know
we like to give disabled people a leg up
where we can or we sh and we should and
sometimes we don't but it's the same
thing it's like if everyone's standing
behind a hedge trying to watch a horse
race and uh there's a really short
person and a child and then there's a
man and he's he can see over the top but
no one else can give the other people a
little boost up right mm-hmm you say
here you can see do you think women do
you think women need to be boosted i
don't i'm not saying that they need to
be boosted up but i'm saying where for
example
you know like for example in terms of
strength okay like
just on a basic level if you've got um
like women need to be protected
from other men funnily enough but it's
the same thing it's like you know we
can't
not everyone can do
everything does that make sense so when
you've got like it's just a society
thing we should all be given the
opportunity to have a view does that
make sense that men and women should
both be sorry you said a lot of
different so i'm not i'm not sure
exactly let me put it in more of a
context of like let's say parliament for
example okay right um
a very male run institution
technically the government has been male
run for centuries right
um it's it it only takes
we need women's voices in there right
that sometimes means giving them a
platform or or someone giving them a
platform you know people don't always
just get heard someone has to say hey
look listen to this person you know what
i mean yeah well sort of because my
question is does it matter what their
gender is like because like don't we
just want the most competent people in
those roles regardless of gender no 100
yeah 100 but where you've got a lot of
misogyny the same way in which you've
got racism
it's a it's a it's a
it's a roadblock okay it's a roadblock
to that and unfortunately those
bad
ideologies tend to fester in groups of
i want to say close-minded people okay
i'm we're going to come back to some of
this but i'm going to let them talk
first about so feminism would you
consider yourself a feminist and what
does it mean to you um i absolutely
would not consider myself a feminist no
um
and to me again i think it's a bit of a
cloudy
region i think some people have taken
the idea of feminism
up there
whereas um
it's i think it's pretty
not basic it's pretty
what's your common knowledge
you know what women should be able to do
and no
but i do not know i'm not a feminist and
i don't have strong women views like
that okay
in my liberal days um
i consider myself a feminist but i do
believe the the basic fundamental
ideology about equal rights and equal
opportunity but you know uh what about
equal laughs
[Laughter]
listen things have just gone left now so
it's at a point where
um i don't people don't know what
feminism is no more people don't know
what aspect of feminism to identify with
and i think the basic level of feminism
now is very extreme it's become a
like almost like a misandry machine um
and i think that's quite problematic for
society isn't by and large so i would i
wouldn't consider myself a feminist
today no okay
so um i was i just googled like the
definition i said what does feminism
what is feminism fought for so it says
activists fought for gender issues
women's sexual liberation reproductive
rights
job opportunities for women violence
against women and changes in custody and
divorce laws it is believed the feminist
movement gave detention gained attention
in 1963 betty fried
fryden frieden public published her
novel okay that was that's the rest of
them i'm not gonna read the rest of that
but so my question is do you think that
women's sexual liberation was good for
women
so oh
when you say sexual liberation can you
expand on that being a hoe
so being partially partially being
being of hope but particularly the
development of birth control in the
1960s that that's what changed the game
right because before when girls slept
around there was always the consequence
of possibly getting pregnant but once
you added birth control into it it takes
away the consequence because you can get
an iud and you have a 99 point whatever
percent chance of not getting pregnant
and
what was the question again is
sex is women's sexual liberation
good for women
i'm gonna say no okay just because of
what you've i don't believe i don't like
the idea of birth control i don't like
the fact that it was created just for
women
and so yeah i'm auntie that so
okay what about you i think
um
oh god
it def
it didn't
yeah i'd say it didn't just because of
the fact that um
i feel like
women um
it's so i'm trying to like think of like
a best way to say it basically no i
don't agree that it has helped women
um to be liberating
um but then
again
when it comes to birth control
i feel like i don't necessarily feel
like birth control
helped women be more liberating
necessarily
um
i didn't i don't think they do it for
men they do it for themselves but not
not to have sex
um
whenever whenever or wherever they
wanted
women women so women aren't on birth
control to have sex whenever they want
some women choose not to have children
um regardless not everyone wants to have
children
um
so
when they
like the only purpose of birth control
was to have sex without having kids
no but i mean
um i mean i know some people do it for
acne too i'll i'll put that in there and
for menstrual yeah yes yes um but that's
why i say it's not solely
just
to not have babies mm-hmm but wouldn't
you say the majority
is it's for
majority it is majority is yeah
um i need to preface this by saying that
i can't have children okay so i know
nothing about birth control i've never
had a period in my life um speaking to
the mic i've never sorry you're right
i'll tell you what let me bring it
around here
um i've never had a period in my life
i've never taken obviously never taken
birth control don't need to um
but
my general views on sexual liberation
are that um
yes it's helped
because i mean realistically if
if we're all under the illusion right
that women were having great orgasms and
you know and really enjoying sex with
their forced marriage husbands like i
just don't think that's a reality
i'm almost certain that i know people
from two generations before me you know
my grandma and whatever that that didn't
even enjoy sex and i bet your bottom
dollar the reason they didn't enjoy sex
is not because sex is not enjoyable for
them if they it's done right
it's because
they never had she was with one man a
whole life like i don't know but how can
you know that's what you want right
um on the other hand i don't think that
um we we don't do as well in
relationships
yes right i'm sorry out of relationships
so for example i mean i struggle to
orgasm more with uh casual partners
it takes me at least a few times to get
into it and get comfortable with them
and whatever i think that's our that's
our
what do you call it it's like our
um
like a like a fierce you know what i
mean it's like a you need to get to know
someone because especially sex is a very
intimate act and it can make you as a
woman i think so i hope you'd all agree
feel it so so if um if you're saying
that women tend to have better sex in
relationships
wouldn't it make more sense that like
back then people used to get married and
have a relationship yeah and then they'd
be in one long-term relationship because
i think number one the sex education
that you have before that relationship
is never
it's never good enough to let to tell
people exactly what they need to be
doing um number two i think that to be
quite honest with you like in our
current you know climate we have
multiple relationships through our lives
which teach us
things i don't think we're monogamous
creatures well they also traumatize you
oh yeah of course they do but yeah but
life is traumatizing in so many ways you
don't think it's like better to have
less relationships than more
i mean i mean to a certain degree
because because every time you have you
know if you have a relationship you you
have a heartbreak right to a to a
certain degree i'm not done
yeah but at the same time i just don't
think you can learn everything you need
to learn from one relationship your
whole life it's just not feasible what
are the things that you think they're
not learning
well well well frank's
because arguably you mention your your
grandparents right so you said that you
should argue she wasn't having good sex
but then what was her what's her metric
for good and bad sex well i mean look i
didn't sit there and have like no i'm
just curious
what would the metric be um
because how would she know if she's only
had sex with one person
that's exactly my point yeah but i'm
saying like like so
i'll give you a stat right if a woman's
a virgin when she gets married she has
an 80 chance of being a happy marriage
after 10 years
80 chance okay um on the other hand if a
girl's had sex with more than five
partners it drops to 25 percent
so
yeah and and
i think in the modern day and age most
guys will pray for five partners
i just um i mean look this is the only
problem i have with statistics as much
as i like to follow them to a certain
degree obviously we have to right but i
just think
you know when it comes to
reportedly happy marriages i mean really
what is a
fulfilling relationship
a fulfilling relationship well one one
that la i think one metric you can use
is how long it lasts one that lasts but
i mean but i mean realistically
realistically if if we're going by the
premise that women
the the statistic you just said which
means that women would be faithful to
their husband their whole lives right do
you really think their husbands are
being faithful to them
so so is their marriage actually happy
and are they really happy would they
really be happy if they knew the
realities of their marriage which is
probably that their husband was playing
around at some point so so two things
one there's a really big misconception
that that a lot of men are sleeping with
everybody but and the reason that is the
reason women think that men cheat all
the time is because we're all sleeping
with the same ones because if you survey
100 of women on what they want in a guy
they list 20 of men sometimes 15
sometimes 5 percent of men when it comes
to dating apps women only swipe right
between 5 to 20 of the time so it's a
very small percentage of men that even
have the option to cheat
so well well yeah okay but the thing is
i feel like you're talking about stuff
that's modern right
because realistically if we're talking
about marriages in the way that they
used to be that would mean going back in
time when women were oppressed by
marriage
marriage which means that realistically
the husbands having the male privilege
they had would have much more likely
been able to go out and play away i had
an uncle in there a great uncle sorry in
the navy and he used to
he's had a wife back here in england and
he used to go to ports in africa he
loved black women so i've probably got
some black
african cousins somewhere
no but i'm just saying that obviously if
that that was a staple
back in the day that was how things
worked i don't think it was with every
relationship but i think it was a lot
well but i'm saying it's still even like
women haven't changed like women still
want the same things they're just
pickier and pickier and pickier so it's
a smaller and smaller percentage of men
so what i'm saying is the majority of
men don't have the option to cheat it's
hard for a guy to get laid
like on on dating apps like where you
can be the most honest about what you
want right women only swipe right five
percent of the time where men swipe
right fifty percent of the time i mean
men will have sex with a hole in the
wall
but to kind of continue on that point if
you want to make a comparison between
the modern day and and um but back in
the day
men had a lot less access really we
lived in small communities and only
people could sleep with the people that
lived in your immediate vicinity your
uncle was different because he was a
sailor now men have a lot more access
through dating apps but the thing is i
think what you're forgetting is that the
reality of it was is that men um
you know
i don't i don't know the exact time ago
that it was but women actually had to
stay in the house so
men were allowed to galavant and do
whatever they were talking to the mic
sorry men were allowed to galavan around
do whatever they wanted you know like
back in the victorian times ride horses
around the place right while the women
just had to sit at home and
wait for them to come round well like
but but freedom comes with
responsibility right so men also had to
fight in wars well we got to stay home
right so they were forced like they they
get drafted
so so you know women we have my body my
choice men don't when they get drafted
yeah but i mean look we're not living in
times where people get drafted to war
anymore are we i mean well because we're
not in a major war but if that i mean
look what happened in um ukraine yeah
and ukraine all the
feminism went out the window when when
war times came they're like you know
what bring me back to the kitchen
but there goes there goes where i said
there's specific roles in society i do
understand that when men and women have
different strengths and
you know one of one of the things we're
not born to do is fight really
but i definitely think that
the reality is that we've had the reason
why feminism even got so much traction
the reason why we're here today is
because women have felt like we've had
to fight for too long
i certainly have felt like that in my
life and i've had a relatively easy life
i like as i could imagine
in terms of women you know what i mean
like i'm probably in there i'm probably
in the like
top [ __ ] 10 of
women with good lives and privilege you
know what i mean so i can imagine that
um you know there were women in so
what have you felt like you've had to
fight for in 2022 um
my voice well 2022.
well yeah i don't feel like i have to
fight so much now it was okay 2010
um
i think
i think back then it was just
i mean i was i was a model i was very
like fresh young fit i got
very much
predated upon by men um i would even say
that
uh to go as far as to say that it
has
unfortunately like left scars on me um
probably the reason why
uh you know like we're talking about the
um
however many many men you have i do
struggle to find
more meaningful relationships
um
but
again i you know that that's
that was
what i feel like was the oppression you
know i was like oh you're just a pretty
like men literally saw me as that just
face like they could manipulate me use
me well but that's that's the job to be
pretty
what would you mean a modeling no yeah
i'm not saying that modeling was the
reason why
before modelling it was that you know
what i mean
so even before modeling yeah yeah yeah
because to me like being beautiful is an
advantage there's there's like people
are treated pretty privileged people are
treated better if they're pretty they
get shorter sentencing like for prison
time no okay they're like no i'm serious
like that you get you're more likely to
get a job interview like being attract
like in the top 20 of beauty so being
being in the top 20 of beauty where you
could actually get a modeling contract
like that's a huge advantage in the
world yeah no
no there were advantages that i had i'm
not saying that yeah but um
i mean look certainly we have to
remember that my mental state when i was
16 17 18 when every girl
first went out to have sex and
like it was not the same
like sex was painful
20 times before it became all right um
so so i'm curious you said marriage you
felt like it was an oppressive structure
for women could you talk more about that
you said something like that earlier i
don't think it's an oppressive thing now
okay but i think the institution as a as
a whole yeah i mean look it's
for hundreds of years it was women being
told who they had to marry not who they
could love
open and freely right
um
and i just think that
you know
the the fact is that no woman has a last
name that is her own
right
you know even if she chooses to keep her
last name that's her father's last name
it's just it just seems a little bit
crazy to me that every you know what i
mean i'm not crazy to me because i know
this is just how things work but
at the same time i don't think we should
have to buy into it like that you know
what i mean i just don't think that we
we need to carry on i think we could
have successful relationships without
the institution of marriage you know
what i mean signing a contract to say oh
i'm gonna love you till the day i die
i'm gonna be there in sickness and in
health and blah blah blah mate listen as
soon as [ __ ] as soon as women get
sick men run out the door so
i mean so question do you guys think
that women are good at picking men um
just go around nah
nah i would i wouldn't say so no
probably not
no i don't no definitely so so couldn't
we say that that was an advantage back
then because i think men vet other men
better than women do
because because because we just said
women aren't good at picking men right
and like every single person in the room
and the problem is like a lot of women
will go after like let's take sierra
right she'll she'll go after future
while she's young and then and then
settle down with russell wilson russell
wilson was the husband but she went for
future first and so it's like
like i think if we had more parental
involvement in these decisions like we
maybe would be able to pick a little bit
better yeah but but you know what that
is though that's the women equivalent of
the male um wifey and [ __ ] thing okay
right tell me more about that yeah right
so basically um
men obviously tend to have a type of
woman that they want to you know wife up
quite often that woman i don't think um
lives up to their sexual expectations
um maybe even
because she wants to be a wife and a
mother she ends up
doing more of that maybe she even not
her fault becomes a mother to him i
think that happens
how isn't that your fault what do you
mean oh it's not her fault that she
became a mother
not to him
no i'm so you were
well because obviously sometimes
relationships just happen and so yeah
you pick the guys you date
mm-hmm
yeah no you do pick the girls yeah yeah
you do but i i still think there's
we're all living
life on this weird rock like it's not
it's small okay but sorry i i
interrupted you go back to so you were
talking about there's there's a wifey
and there's a [ __ ] right so so and then
they have two different
girls that they go for but i i think
something tends to happen with men more
is that at the beginning
when they're younger for example they
they might
look at the girls who are a wife you put
them on pedestals oh she looks like i i
remember when i was younger boys would
always say oh that girl she's wifey
material and they would tolerable right
yes but then i was a stripper right and
so i spent a lot of time
sitting with men who would come in
looking for the opposite of their blonde
well
yeah but there's a there's a difference
between sexual attention and
relationship attention so i mean i got a
guy again a guy will screw a hole in the
wall like i've had guys say things about
a girl where they're like oh she was
better than my hand
and so yeah and so that's what i'm
saying so
i wish a guy would be better than my
hand
so no but no so that's not that's not
the point it's not it's not tick for tat
i'm saying like men can compartmentalize
a little bit better than women can
because they're not as picky
so so a guy can have sex with a girl
that he absolutely despises hates never
wants to see again where women typically
they have to have some sort of emotional
connection well i mean biology and
whatever
yes yeah yeah so so i mean those guys
were probably talking about that girl
that's like the the one they want to
marry where like the other the other
girls like they're just trying to jack
off to her no
yeah no i don't no i disagree no no no
what else would you go to a strip club
for oh yeah but this is the thing what
you have to remember is that these men
fall in love with these women i'm
telling you it is not a it is not a
completely oh your wank bank type thing
men get obsessed with [ __ ] they love
[ __ ] in fact i've seen a couple of
videos on tiktok where some man saying
men don't love slap yes they do yes they
do when you say you love [ __ ] what do
you mean like was it like leave their
wife for her or just
no i mean i mean
not necessarily leave their wife but
can't leave them alone will happily
cheat on their wife for the rest of
their life with the [ __ ]
but the [ __ ] probably doesn't even want
him that's what i'm saying right because
she's in her strength
doing her thing
right
so um and i'm just saying it's the same
thing with them
with the women who go for the future and
then they go for the safe option right
it's just because realistically there's
something very animalistic about the guy
who and and probably he gives you a
better sex i i bet you that there's
better sex there so yeah i would guess
that that's probably part of it right
but but does that lead to long-term
happiness for women getting ran through
by by the few by getting ran through by
the futures in their 20s and then
settling down with that with the russell
wilson's in their 30s does that equate
to wait kind of finish so does does that
equate to longer marriages happier
marriages and does that equate to better
results so and the only reason she's
able to do that is because of the
development of birth control
well i mean look i don't think it
necessarily
um because because again again back then
like your parents were involved right
and you also had to think of if if
future gives me pregnant is he going to
stick around is it no no i do i think
future's going to do with baby mom i
don't i don't know
i don't know i don't know i thought he'd
pay i don't i don't know what he's doing
but but
but like like that's why you had to
prioritize the the beta side of
hypergamy you would you would prioritize
like the the long-term security over the
short-term fun
before where now it's like yeah you can
have the best sex of your life but is he
going to stay
and is that and if he leaves are you
going to be hurt in the long run
yeah and will that ruin your husband a
little bit for you because now your
husband has to deal with all this trauma
from your past relationships
well
i mean it's a difficult one because i've
never been married and i don't know but
my first relationship was abusive and
he was a really really horrible guy and
i can't believe i ever fell in love with
him i feel embarrassed now right when i
look back on it i think wow wasted my
first bit of my 20s like what the hell
was i doing
um but i
never felt like that before
i didn't know how to end it i couldn't
end it and then he was manipulat like he
was emotionally abusive and then he
became physically abusive then i got
into a relationship with a guy who i
would still consider the love of my life
i'm not over him and
uh yeah i bled all over him i i i had i
had all the cuts and i was just bleeding
all over him and it [ __ ] my
relationship yeah so i'm saying like you
know maybe if there's more parental
involvement you could be married by now
i mean i don't i don't know your family
i don't really want to be married i
don't think but i definitely want to be
in a strong partnership
okay so i mean maybe not married maybe
marriage isn't what you're looking for
but but you want a long-term partner i
think most people do right yeah so and
you know maybe if had you not had that
trauma but the only reason you could do
that is because we took out parental
involvement because no dad's gonna let
his daughter deal with a dude that's
abusive
yeah but how do you know that because
okay your dad can choose a man but
he won't really know the man yeah
there's been
for example arranged marriages by
parents still is yeah and
yeah till this day and
you know it's the parents that's
selecting this partner for you and
there's been women who've been murdered
abused
so i'm curious as women why do we always
go to the extreme well because it's the
reality yeah no but but it's not do you
think the majority of men are abusive no
so so so it's an exception
no i mean it's it's i'm only just
stating because
from my understanding from what you said
it's like
this doesn't happen
so that's why i stated what i said well
i'm saying there are exceptions right
but but the data is pretty clear when it
says that places that have arranged
marriages where there's more parental
involvement there tends to be longer
marriages
because because then again usually the
families would bet each other too so i
mean everyone knows who the crazy kid in
your family is right like like if
everyone has a crazy sibling if
someone's someone knows they're crazy
it's the siblings we we all know right
and so they're gonna find that out a
little bit better than they would where
you just meet a guy off a tinder go on a
couple dates hook up sleep together for
three years and then live together maybe
call maybe get married at the end of it
maybe get a kid and get divorced but i'm
sorry i'm sorry
the problem is with that right
that's the number one way people are
meeting nowadays is online uh right yeah
which which is terrible i hate that i
hate that fact so i think it's the worst
but
when you're talking about the families
vetting the families for the marriages
that you know
not necessarily arranged but whatever
right
you say oh they lived in longer
marriages but like really is that are
they not just sucking it up because they
don't want to settle
how important is love in america because
i think we can draw a direct comparison
between i think i think love is the most
important thing personally sorry you
think love's the most important thing so
then why marriage is lasting then
because if more people if more women now
marry for love
i um
logically more marriages will last
longer whereas prior did not marry for
love it was out of necessity or
well i think there was a still a mixture
of both you have to remember that
obviously for example if you had a small
town most people did grow up in small
towns back in the day there was cities
weren't as big as they are now right
um so you used to find that
the the the people who
would be you know let's just betroth or
whatever they were um
yeah they may have actually had
um
may have met each other and had a
flirtation or whatever so there was
definitely love that could have been
built from that right it's totally
different from if if a
family's
shipping their daughter off to someone
from thousands of miles away or
something i don't know and i think that
happens too but
um
i i think the the problem is is that
just because there's no love in a
marriage doesn't make it a good or a
happy i'm not saying necessarily there's
no love i'm just saying there's a direct
comparison between
old school marriages and modern
marriages arguably modern marriages have
more love but
modern marriages don't last anymore and
the main reason for them not lasting is
women initiating divorces for um various
reasons yeah well obviously various
reasons and i i think it's a it's one of
those things that unfortunately we'd
like to say it was women's fault for
divorce because you know wait is that
yeah well you say it's their fault but
they don't want to initiate divorces
yeah but the initiation doesn't doesn't
doesn't 18 to 90 of the time doesn't
stop
what brought them to that point how do
we know
how their marriage has been yeah to push
them right
to say i don't want to be because
because because cheating statistics are
similar
so so men and women yes between between
men and women yeah but so so they're
getting equally become more similar
and same 20 years ago right but we're in
2022 now and so that's why he's saying
it's their fault because again cheating
statistics are similar right even even
abuse like actually men in most abusive
relationships people are abusing each
other so it's not one-sided they're both
abusive towards each other and the
majority of one-sided abuse it's
actually more women are one-sidedly
abusive to men than men are to women
so that means like they're not hitting
back
so it's one-sided so sorry sorry wait
can you
okay so the majority of abusive
situations are mutually abusive so that
means the man's hitting the woman the
woman's hitting the man
so that's the majority of abuse cases
i'm sorry where did you get that
statistic from so it's actually a
feminist actually went in and did the
research on this so she was an
ex-feminist she did a whole documentary
basically looking into the men's rights
movement and then she came across so
that that data set comes from that
documentary okay
by the way my
but i have a small group of best friends
every single one of them has been an
abusive relationship i'm telling you
we only fight back when we have to we
are scared
but but but here is there is not one
part of me that believes that
all
most most abusive relationships
one-sided abuse i didn't say i didn't
say mutually i said one-sided abuse i
thought you i thought you just said no
so i said most abusive relationships
they're abusing each other yeah which is
mutually obvious yes but i don't believe
that okay well
i don't i don't believe that's true i i
don't know what study this woman did but
it doesn't sound true to me especially
with my experiences my friends
experiences it just doesn't ring true
well i mean we could go over the data
later if you want but like it's it's
from a reputable source
so so what i'm saying though is
basically
if if the cheating stats are similar the
if we look at the abuse statistics women
are more abusive towards men than men
are towards women because think about it
women can get away with it more
that's why i believe it because if you
take away the consequences for someone
they're going to do it more i'm not
saying that women like like men and
women are equally capable of abuse but
women don't always go to jail for i mean
look at what happened in miami
with that that only fan's model she
killed her boyfriend yeah and she's
walking free right now if the roles were
reversed it wouldn't happen so if you
take away the consequences in a society
they're gonna do it more
like to me to me that makes sense
so
it that's why he's saying that it's
the woman's fault because
we both have problems but the women is
the one leaving
[Music]
can i um just add something to that so
when you said there's um
you said the stats for marriages with
parental
guidance basically last longer right
yep okay so with that don't you think
marriage is like that anyway so let's
just say arrange marriage or things like
that usually involve let's say religion
a cultural aspect things like that you
wouldn't just out of your own back if
you have no none of that like cultural
religion you wouldn't be like yeah mum
go find me a husband like i don't i
don't think you would so don't you think
because of that they last longer because
one both of you because you're both
families are involved you're not going
to speak out
fear of being judged
also probably
speaking out or going your separate ways
is
looked bad upon
there's so many other reasons hence the
fact the stats might show that but i'm
saying there's so many aspects as to why
women won't leave that kind of situation
so i i agree with you i do think part of
it is there was less shame back then in
doing it i also i also agree that
there's religious
reasons that people stay but the point
is when there's a family the kids are
more important than you
so it's about duty over love
this is where they stay like several
friends in relationships that their
parents put them in speaking to them
sorry and the lady is she's quite a bit
older than me she has two kids she loves
her husband she's not in love with her
husband and she was put together with
him and she's going through something
right now where she doesn't know what to
do she doesn't know him to leave and go
find a new life because she's obviously
she's happy she has kids and she has a
partner but they were put together and
it's not that she's in love with him
she's just been told this is what you
should be doing so she's staying for the
children because she knows it's the
right thing this this is what scares men
is they can put a lifetime of resources
into a woman and she'll leave because
she doesn't feel like she's in love
anymore because feelings come and go
like this is why men don't want to get
married i don't think she was ever in
love to begin with she was put into that
situation she was never in love with
this man she had children with this man
because her parents told her she should
so she has love for him she's he's the
father of her kids but she's not in love
with how old is she she's
38 i'd say a couple years older than me
38 and she doesn't know whether she
wants to stay or go no well no how old
how old are the kids they're big they're
grown they're great they're grown kids
but she feels like if she walks away now
because she's put together the family
the family are going to look down on her
right well i mean i think there should
be shame and divorce
yeah bring back shame
i mean
i think it depends on the city yeah
not really if you put yourself in the
situation yeah but if you're forced how
old was she she was young she was 15. if
you get married at 15. yes i'll give her
a pass fifteen she's gonna be honest
that's what i mean a lot of arranged
marriages are that yeah they are not in
2022 the average age of first marriage
is 27 and 28 and even back then it was
over the age of 18. sorry are we not
talking about very
western statistics here
right but so but so on isn't well that's
why we're talking about the west like
this conversation is how feminism
destroyed marriage right but the problem
yeah but the problem with that is that
the reality of it is that with the
cultural um clashes in the uk right now
we don't have just a
if you say
our people are getting married at a
certain that's white people right
no it's all well is it just is it really
no no it's it's in the you the the okay
i'll tell you where i got the stats okay
20 in the u.s of all people the average
age of first marriage is 27 almost 28
for for women right and in the uk it's
actually 31. okay so it's older here
that's across yeah right okay and i
guess i guess america's more
multicultural than the uk is it
um i think it's like what fifty percent
white people
i mean i would say it's the majority
white i know i know yeah what are we
thirteen percent here um something like
that i thought it was so much more than
that it's way lower yeah
well i think i think i think it matters
because um because the reality of it is
that cultural implications feed into
society as a whole
you know we're not we're not talking
even even if you can say yes we're a
majority white people
you know we have to
we have to kind of take into account
that we're not we're not talking about
just white people you know what i mean
i i knew we were not talking about just
white people no no no i'm just saying
you didn't i'm not saying you didn't but
i'm saying that
when you say about that specific
statistic it just feels very so like
well what implications does that have on
marriage and what you like
what senses
first marriage hold on i'm gonna look up
well because okay so for example right
you have to look at it like this um the
western cultures have become
such an economic force right that
basically everything that they do
is um
to
further progression in the western idea
average age of first marriage is 22. so
it's not like 15 or something like that
all right
but that's not that's good isn't it yeah
it's not back then
i can do historically actually yeah
but i mean evening even england had
probably at some point girls getting
married at 14 years old right i mean you
know it happened that you're right but
it happens everywhere that's fine but
i'm saying that okay so now for example
i heard this the other day i think um
in the western world if you look at any
decision that governments make
in the name of progression look behind
it there's probably an economic reason
why they're saying it so we've just
obviously had roe v wade overturned in
the u.s
now the reality of that situation is
that there's actually less women having
babies which means that the workforce is
becoming depleted and that governments
need
bottom workers
so that so
there's a there's a
if you stop so
versus wade did not ban abortion in the
u.s
sorry roe vs wade did not ban abortion
in the u.s what do you mean it didn't so
so a lot of people in the uk assume that
it banned abortion but that's not the
case so in some states they can they can
ban abortion but they haven't so far
right so but
but okay but so i wasn't necessarily
saying about how roe v wade banned
abortion but certainly something to do
with that okay meant that most of
america was under the the guys of
if you want an abortion you can get one
you've got clinics most states
were free to do that right
yeah so the number one provider of
abortion in the us is planned parenthood
or do you know that yes yeah so did you
know that planned parenthood is actually
a racist organization
i i've heard
little bits about that yeah yeah finally
yeah that's that's fine but but this no
but no but it's not fine but i mean it
all it all feeds into my exact thoughts
okay go ahead but this is economic
decisions okay it's not about
progression it's not about
you know what i mean it's not about um
also so we actually care about these
people it's about what's best for the
economy well no no that that wasn't what
was best for the so a lot of people
don't understand how the legal system
works in the u.s so what is
this was a decision based on states
rights and um federal rights so in the
u.s typically
it's state by state you can decide if a
law um yeah
and so what this did is said the states
can decide for themselves so if you live
in a state you can vote one way or the
other and then that way the laws better
represent the people in each state
and if you don't like it you can move to
another state it's pretty easy right i
think that was made pretty clear to be
fair i got that from what i've been
reading
but okay so so
i i don't i don't know whether the point
i was trying to make got miss right okay
um so for example
look back again once again to the
beginning of the feminist movement right
um
as far as i'm aware that was in the
early 1900s right the the main one of it
right so um
at that time funnily enough we had world
war one right what happened in world war
one well all the men got drafted off to
do the fighting in the war right now so
women had to take up the jobs back home
women had to do the engineer work and
actually that's funny because it made
loads of women go out and say oh hey
mentally and physically yeah okay we
can't fight men in the same but we can
do we can
pick up a spanner and fix an airplane or
you know what i mean it gave gave women
all these ideas that we can do this
stuff
guess what it was an economic decision
even though they had to fight and there
was
marches and whatever well in the end the
government said hey hold on a minute
women are actually going to bring us
more taxes they're going to bring us
more everything
it works for the economy let's just yeah
go for it come on
why would you not
i'm just
women in the workforce helps the economy
is what i'm saying okay yeah it does
right but so i just didn't understand
what that had to do with roe versus wade
right so it has so for example i'm
saying that roe versus where this
overturning of roe versus wade is an
economic decision
nothing to do with the men who made this
decision to say
we we don't want women having abortion
it's under the guise of religion but it
was a misinterpretation of the
constitution that's what it was so so
basically when they when they initially
looked at the cons because the the only
the supreme court justice's job is to
interpret the constitution right and so
what the supreme court justices did
today was they said that back in the i
want to say was the 70s 60s when roe
versus wade happened right that it was a
misinterpretation and that was not what
the founders would have wanted because
when you think about it the founders
like they weren't talking about
abortions back then that wasn't readily
available no
so so there's no way that they could
have
granted that as a right but again that's
what i'm saying i don't think it was an
economic decision it was it was no it
wasn't it might not have been an
economic decision
when they wrote the constitution
but the fact
sorry this is what i don't understand
why is america still going off this one
you know that in the constitution it
says that this should be revised every
19 years has it been
not
revised revised every 19 years that's
what it says in the constitution
apparently as far as i've as far as my
research goes so
that hasn't happened uh americans die on
the constitution the second amendment
right to bear arms hold on a minute i
don't think the founding fathers
realized that you know you were going to
be able to carry around
47
the founding fathers the founding
fathers
i don't want to get too off topic
but the founding fathers did like
because the whole point of the right to
bear arms is protection against the
government so that they were okay with
people having lethal weapons because if
the government overtakes you then you
can fight back that's the whole point of
the second amendment okay so it it
wasn't about what type of weapons that
they had no
no but what i was saying i'm saying that
the founding fathers wouldn't have i'm
sure if they could see into the future
and had seen that that was
no that's happening now they might have
said let's amend this right no it's
called the amendment no but i'm saying i
i don't think they would have because
again like the whole point was to let
the people be able to defend the gov
like from the government right but the
problem is that guns aren't being used
to defend against the government these
days are they
right but the the problem is that it
could but
this is so off topic all right i i
understand what you're saying i just
don't think it is it's not off topic is
actually exactly the point i'm trying to
make it's it's it's it might seem like
it's coming from back then but the
reality of it is is that
everything that's happening now
is is a result of what happened back
then
right in in the u.s
everywhere
everywhere
i just don't get the point you're making
okay um but
the point i'm making is is right back
back then
it was it was it feasible to say
right to bear arms it was feasible in
the 60s or whatever it was with the
abortion or whatever it was feasible at
those times
because it fed into economy that's what
i'm saying
if you look at no but again again that
was the
that was to protect from government
tyranny so for example if if the jews in
germany were all they had
guns it would have been harder to take
them and put them in an internment camp
that that's what why we have the right
to bear arms
is for like for protection against the
government
right
i don't know i just don't know if um
they had have had guns whether that
would have stopped the holocaust i i
personally think that when there is a
power like an army it doesn't matter how
many guns people have
like there's still
someone who's gonna
manage i mean government money with
tanks got it's just how is someone with
a gun in their house going to be able to
fight against that's a massive
assumption not really like you don't
know what would happen in that
circumstance i don't but no i do i know
it's death death would happen
but yeah yeah but at least you could
fight back but i'm i'm gonna read super
chats because this is getting kind of
off topic
so
okay so guys as you know we are raising
money to get it a camera
let's go
so all of your donations are going
towards getting ish a camera if you want
to know what he looks like send a super
chat okay
keys prime time she just said men
decided this but there is three females
on the supreme court panel get her
educated house of has they think the
worst of men that's why they go to the
worst percentage as examples these women
have a disdain for men shame on you all
hate is in their hearts for men
wendell coven you cannot legally carry
around an ak-47 sentience did women get
married younger in years the past but
you conveniently forgot the average life
expectancy for men and women was shorter
also missed the big point that feminism
erased cultural boundaries regarding
marriage i also looked up the average
age of first marriage in the u.s from
1890 was 22 so it wasn't like they were
getting married at 15. um on top of that
john jonathan adams kick her out please
brit cormier i love how after every stat
pearl pulls up the woman
changed the reference point that is now
not then we are talking about white
people we were only talking about
western culture it cracks me up
selective service tv why are modern
women pushing this narrative about love
is the most important thing when
children and commitment are the most
important helen leslie as a woman myself
women like to say that they are
they baby men by cleaning cooking
folding clothes for them men can say
they father women by bringing them
financial stability handle your
insecurities brit
cormier for the majority of history a
marriage was a business contract between
families so the families picked the best
matches they could find people did their
duty to the family you would fall out of
love with any partner given time vincent
dole lacil masculine chick on the left
side of the couch is confused and
scrambling to make sense she will be
alone and a stripper it is an is not a
model uh sentients ladies men want
sorry men want 304s just for fun in the
short term they want chase virtuous
women who are sexually inexperienced in
whom they can mold as wives and mothers
only simps fall in love with with [ __ ]
not the worthwhile men omegza
gaming channel that's not love it's lost
and feminism is lame brit cormier
by that logic no man has a last name
that is his own even if he keeps his
name it is his father's name sentience
women have largely forgotten the dangers
of the world men protected them from
hence the reasons of what people did in
the past try an actual education rather
than being indoctrinated but
indoctrinated by social media where did
you find this one eddie throw her back
sentience i i feel that i feel like then
proceeds to talk about happiness in
marriage women have long forgotten that
marriage is and was a duty to the family
not the narcissistic women as for
gallivanting men these were men who had
money common men walked
um sentience has feminism ruined
marriage look you look at non-feminists
with five boyfriends even if she had
less the the term boyfriends over dating
now you have modern misandrists who
label other misandrists that don't share
their ideology couple feminist
ideologies with hyper unbridled
sexuality along with shaming those who
warn them of the dangers of the path
they tread on and you have wanton 304s
who lack morals and foundations that are
vital for a healthy family
i think that's all the super chats let
me just refresh real quick
okay so um
okay there's a couple more
the
ovi hussein look at how being armed is
working out for the ukraine the second
amendment is basically rambo three coast
play that americans like to do the uk
economist many single mothers who choose
bad men now have young boys who are in
gangs and are out of control wouldn't
vetting meant these men
be better for society so we can raise
kids in more stable homes i might
actually ask that one in a second brett
cormier does she not live through the
u.s for war in afghanistan u.s has the
most equipped fighting forces in all of
history still did not win that war even
with those tanks and nukes declan flynn
the us is the largest most powerful army
in the world we just lost a 20-year war
we
just lost a 20-year war against some
farmers with guns house of has advice
from their dad seems embarrassing to
them nightingale 21 come on you guys we
need more likes and subscribers
stephen mitchell second amendment she is
so uneducated tell her to look up the
vietnam and show her the crowder video
on 2a swell city i'm losing brain cells
you're all over the place helen leslie
women go to the extremes with examples
so no one can say their view is wrong if
you go against the radical view they say
you support toxicity even though you
don't i care for male victims i was
called to pick me by feminist pa hiki
award this woman with a gold medal for
mental gymnastics in a single sentence
keys prime time she just said men
decided but this is the three females on
the supreme court judge so um i actually
thought this was a good question
many single mothers who choose bad men
now have young boys who are in gangs and
out of control do you think vetting
these men for to
wouldn't vetting men wouldn't men
vetting these men be better for society
so we can raise kids in a more stable
home
do you want to start on that side oh
yeah work your way around because
um would it be better of course it would
be um i always say that um when it comes
to these type of conversations that you
know you shouldn't really take advice
from women in that sense because
men are better able to identify the
the bad traits than men i don't think
you can leave that to women and i think
society now is a perfect example of what
happens when you leave women to their
own devices and now women are picking
their own men and what is now happening
is a lot more women are going through
trauma obviously we have the body count
conversation um and a lot less
unhappy marriages or unhappy
relationships and that's a direct
consequence of women having more
autonomy over the partners that they
choose
again this while you know in the
previous conversation i was taking them
back to the difference between um having
you know the old-school relationships
and initial relationships parents being
involved and fathers being involved in
their lives
was able to have women pick better men
which had longer lasting relationships
when we look to most of our parents um
in that generation they were together
and we are the consequence of our
parents being together in stable
situations so why is it that now you
know we have the choice we are actively
choosing to create situations of
instability just because of sex so i
think yeah
bring back men in relationships
marriages are important
and you're going to fix ups though i
think it also depends in what kind of
situation that you grow up in as well
like i do agree like my grandparents on
both sides stay together their whole
entire lives you know like with my mom's
side i there was nothing my nan adored
my granddad he was everything with my
dad's side there was some things that
went on that a woman now would never put
up with but growing up i do think to
myself had i have
maybe put up with a couple of things i
probably would have stayed with my
daughter's dad and i probably would have
been happy in the long run had i have
put up with it but
growing up in the environment that i
grew up in i was like i'm not putting up
with this i'm not dealing with that i
suppose that was like my little bit of
feminism like no i'm not doing it
whereas
in reality i probably should have stuck
it out and worked on it do you know what
you mean and i think a lot of people
aren't prepared to stick it out and work
on it
feminism
it's feminist for feminism to prevail he
needs an enemy and it's obviously made
the mortal enemy of the patriarchy so he
needs to feel that war so what it does
now is it shows a lot of women these
circumstances and say the grass is
always green but in reality the grass
isn't always greener so obviously we
mentioned men stepping out and looking
at [ __ ] but
in in in these scenarios like he comes
back home he doesn't he still he still
has a family in these in a lot of these
situations whereas again when we look at
the the opposite side if a woman is
falls out of love with a man the
relationship's done um so i do think
yeah you're definitely right in terms of
if you if you work at things we humans
deprive best when they deal with
adversity when we have things given on a
plate to us it's problematic but if but
if what you think if a man falls out
of love with a woman no no no so most
many leave a relationship so even if a
man steps out this is why i say when it
comes to sex between men and women it's
completely different if a woman is
stepping out on a game having sex with
another guy the relationship's
practically done if a man is doing it
he's still wholeheartedly in love with
his woman as you mentioned before these
guys are happily married but they had to
love the [ __ ] they love a [ __ ] but
they're still getting home to their
wives a woman's not going home too much
she's breaking up the family that's the
direction if he's going home to an
unhappy wife i'm telling you that now
you're saying that anecdotally like you
don't know that for certain
yeah why is that
why i know you're why is that your
automatic assumption it's not my
assumption it's what they tell me who
tells you men that their wife's are
unhappy or they they're unhappy with
their wives i can't leave her we've got
two kids together they're lying
they're lying i don't think well there's
there's there's a couple there's a
couple things like i think men
understand better than women that
happiness comes and goes
so they might not be happy now but
it doesn't mean they can't become happy
later and men are more willing to stick
it out where women just leave at the
drop of a hat you know that one of the
one of the biggest uh reasons why um
marriages break down apart from cheating
is just no sex
right yeah but i'm sorry but that's
typically the woman who doesn't give it
to the man yeah but why
why
so why do you think it is well i
personally my personal um view on this
is that men
do not do enough
in a relationship to make a woman feel
like sexy enough to have right
men have this modern woman men have no
no no this i i think okay look i i was i
had a i have a condition right my
condition caused me to produce
testosterone when i was younger i was
incredibly horny i found it i found it
incredibly difficult to say no to sex
okay um i had mine
back then
[Laughter]
um i had i had i now have to take hrt so
i now take estrogen and i'm telling you
that there is a difference okay a really
big one okay yeah and
what that makes me feel like is that
there men have a sex drive because i
used to have one but i don't anymore i
have a sex response when a man comes to
me and he flirts with me and he comes to
me and he's he's he's trying to do on me
and he's he's he's like slapping my bum
throughout the day and doing all the
little things that you want out of a
relationship right that's when i get the
horniest
do you know how many times i think men
come to women expectant
of sex within two minutes of kissing
after not giving them enough
okay do you do you think throughout the
day do you do you hold that equally to
women like they have to do enough to
make turn the men on well well of course
yeah yeah okay so i mean okay
so what if she gets fat
oh well hey no i'm saying i'm saying
like is that is that a valid complaint
oh 100 percentage okay yeah yeah oh i
agree with that yeah yeah you don't
think when a man is taking care of the
bills and he's providing financially
that like you owe him that well that you
that you have a duty to have sex with
him
um
that's a difficult question i i don't
think it should feel like a duty so for
example if your man's doing the right
thing
in the right amounts and and by the way
if we're talking about the ways in which
i think men and women should be um
what's the word in their natural
sort of aura let's say
it's
it's um it's exactly that men should be
the leader okay that's that's fine
but i don't think men are leaders these
days so the problem is is that they
expect well because women emasculate
them constantly
or maybe they allow themselves to be
emasculated i mean it's it's tough when
every every sitcom you've seen since you
were a child emasculates the father i
mean look at look at take the simpsons
what's it's a dumb dad the smart mom
like men are told they ain't [ __ ] from a
young age like why why is it okay to say
men or trash men are trash but it's not
okay to say women are [ __ ]
no they're trash too um yeah yeah no i
think that women are no but again i mean
i don't think it's okay to say man of
truth but i'm saying like it's it's just
socially acceptable that's something
that we like that in society people have
talked about how men ain't [ __ ] i mean
look at there's a there's a hit song on
the radio i don't want no scrubs grab it
right yeah but but if the guy said oh i
don't want i don't want no whales it
wouldn't be the same like people would
freak out there's a double standard with
men and for women so they're emasculated
from a young age go ahead but don't you
think that there's a double standard in
general anyway with the way that men
talk about women it's kind of like the
the opposites of each other to just
balance each other out like women are
going to say men ain't [ __ ] about the
stuff that they don't do right and men
are gonna say women are [ __ ] because
they sleep around and men have
let's be honest men have very very uh
i'm gonna say from what i've seen anyway
um
very
sensitive emotions funnily enough
because they say they're all logical but
i've seen way more emotion come from men
based on the smallest things that we do
right
what's more that you do
well well so
so for example um one of the biggest
things i can say is that i
well these days i know when i'm flirting
i think when i was younger i'm just a
nice person i was brought up very nice
and i'm certainly not the kind of person
who can be
overly rude to someone and and the
biggest problem i've had is that men
think i flirt when i'm not so guy you're
seeing might think you're a guy i'm
seeing has well obviously the first
boyfriend i had he took
he blew these tiny little things of me
just having a conversation with the guy
where i wasn't even attracted to him
right he blew it up and then
what do you mean if the way you behave
with other men is perceived as flirting
and you're actively saying that men
think you're flirting
isn't it easy to misconstrue no because
i i think the problem is is that men
so for example
um it's not just about
how
men think that when women are nice
they're flying it's not that we're
flying well but a lot of women will
flirt for attention
that's fair to say that i'm not saying
that's not fair to say but
but there's still a big difference
between flirting and being nice and
having a conversation with someone
what's the what's the difference well
the difference what's the difference
between someone playing hard to get and
flirting
and they're not being interested so
number one i think touching is a big
thing so for example like if i flirt i'm
gonna probably at some point touch a guy
if i have a conversation with a guy
where i'm laughing a couple of times and
with back and forthing that's just a
conversation you think that's on you
though for like the guys you pick
well
well i picked the wrong guy yeah i did i
did but but i do but not overall it's
just the men that i've seen
all have the same thing um i i'm not i'm
not picking because i i don't really
have that problem like like where it's
every time i date someone and i'm a very
i'm like i talk for a living you know
what i mean
and i've just never really had that
problem where men in general are stupid
jealous so it just seems like that's
like an issue with either your ability
to pick or maybe something you're doing
but you have to no but you have to
remember that you have to remember that
jealousy runs on both
it could be a more male 3
or female thing well i i know but i'm
saying if she's in the same situation
over and over again no i'm not
but i've also seen it from other other
women's point of views my friends i've
seen it just out of
like i know these people acquaintances
and i've seen the same thing happen so
wait when you and your girls are
flirting it's off the michigan street
for something else no i'm not flying
when we're just being nice yeah when
you're just being nice people often
think you're flirting so basically the
the the pro well that sounds like that's
a problem with you and your girls
talking about her first boyfriend yeah
yeah i was talking about when i was
younger but then you said also your
friends and i'm saying like in my in my
experience like me and my friends don't
really have that problem so they say
birds of the same feathers flock
together
well no
me and my friends are actually very
different i'm
i'm but i'm saying like it seems like
you're putting that on all men when it
could possibly just be either no i'm not
getting it on all men i was never saying
that i know i never i could roll i could
roll it back on on the clown yeah but i
never said all men did i said men so
that implies all men okay okay okay
um i meant a certain type of man okay
but i meant a certain type of man who is
way more prevalent in our society than i
wish they were
but i i don't
in my experience i think there's more
men that are pretty chill
and they're not really
well
i'm i've met a lot of children too i'm
not saying i haven't
um but i think when you know
when you're in relationships stuff
changes i've met a lot of chill men who
i thought were very chill and then
uh
when you're in a relationship do you
change your behaviors
me yeah so like the way you interact
with other men because that's that's
something i see i'm going to talk about
today um men are insecure because
they're a bit too territorial but when
you're the way you behave when you're
single should be completely different
the way to the way you behave yeah yeah
yeah
is there a difference
but well that's a very difficult
question because i would say if i was to
get into a relationship now yeah that i
valued as much as i did my last
relationship which i [ __ ] up and i
hold my hands up there
but i was
i was
led into that relation it was a
what's the word you know kind of like
free fall
like i went from this abusive scenario
where like stuff was really heavy my
life was heavy
until this man came along but i wasn't
ready for him okay because i hadn't
healed and that was my my problem right
but
that basically led me into a situation
where i couldn't really mentally make
the informed decisions that i would have
done otherwise okay right
so what did you cheat on him or
something yeah i did yeah
yeah i did wait
yeah
yeah i was it was horrible no i hear
that it's the worst thing that ever
happened i would never ever do it again
um
but you know he he did stuff to me too
our relationship sort of spiraled out of
control really okay um
and
yeah i'd say i i take the blame for
starting it off
but um
but you know he he exhibited traits that
were
uh a bit a bit worrying as well you know
what i mean it so your response was
cheat on him
no no no no i mean
after time you know what i mean like
first of all he um he did the thing
where he
i i thought with him a lot about like
trying to help me i was i was always
wanting to do things for myself because
that's how i do it so like the
independent yeah because i'd been with
an abusive guy and like i was always
fighting against him i just felt like
relationships were a fight that's what i
felt like from what i've been through
and then
he once one day
stopped me and was like stop fighting
with me he's like we're a team and i was
like [ __ ] no one's ever given me the
support and like
suddenly i think i put him
way up on a pedestal
and
that
a long
time and
even though
i know what i did wrong i don't think
that me like two wrongs don't make a
right right so you know once i started
trying well i would expect if you're
gonna still be here and you're still
gonna try for a relationship with me you
should also be trying to
rather than
rather than taking advantage of the
situation but you see that's what i
point something out so
we talk about having multiple sexual
partners
or too many sexual partners has been a
problem for long-term successful
relationships but what you're basically
saying here is that because of your past
experiences you met a good guy but he
wasn't able to treat him right because
of your trauma from your previous
relationship so doesn't that then
coincide with the fact that women should
have less sexual partners to alleviate
themselves from these traumas well no
because i just i don't think that
alleviates women from sexual trauma but
there's a contradiction in itself
because your past experiences have led
to current traumas so if you had less
partners obviously this is your first
boyfriend but in most cases you know the
more partners you have the more likely
you are for these sort of situations to
us
i've only ever had two boyfriends
officially we've had more sexual
partners yeah yeah so my point is my
point is if we're going to go off the
premise that too many sexual partners
for women create negative situations
because of the trauma that's it that
inflicts can't you then see the logic in
saying that in your situation or
applying that logic to other people if
you have less sexual partners there is
less chance of these traumatic
experiences
so less more happiness prevails with the
less partners you have or sexual
partners you have
hmm i
i can't say that i don't see a basis of
in tr of truth in that
[Music]
but i just don't feel like we should be
i just i said it's so nuanced because i
just don't feel like taking away sexual
partners brings happiness i feel like
but it brings better results
so because don't you think it's a good
odds 80 chance of a happy marriage if
you're a virgin on your wedding night
well versus i just the average the
average length of a marriage is eight
years and so you're already being still
married you're already above half of the
people
and and the chart if you look at the
chart it's pretty cut and dry it gets
the your chance of divorce goes up and
up and up the more partners you've had i
just don't believe it's happy
i just don't believe they're happy i'm
sorry probably
why wouldn't you believe them if they're
you're asking them isn't it like believe
it or not i mean
i know but i can only go i could only go
off things like my parents relationship
they stayed married until my mom died do
i think they were happy but but it's not
about happiness it's about duty like
it's all so you think everyone should
live their lives on duty yes oh my gosh
yeah especially if you have kids okay if
you have kids that's the difference it's
not about you anymore it's about the
family structure so even even if they
get divorced later in life like that's
still too like because i'm thinking most
of my me and my siblings are out of the
house right because my parents have
there's they're my parents i'm one of
ten right and my parents built a
multi-million dollar business together
and a lot of people think that it's just
sunshine and rainbows no there's years
they hated each other but they stuck it
out and found true love
and and now they're happier than ever
well i mean and so it's like but a lot
of times women aren't willing to stick
out the years of unhappiness right well
my mom did and pick up your mom shout
out to him
you stay big up but no hold on sorry my
dad's a great guy by the way
their marriage was
their marriage went on the rocks due to
bankruptcy and them going into business
together that was the issue right um
it's not that my dad's a bad guy if
anything i'm more of a daddy's girl than
i'm a mommy's guy my mum's a bit toxic
but
what i saw from their relationship
being unhappy a lot of the time i think
had a massively negative effect on due
to finances
due to yeah because that is the primary
reason that women live in relationships
as well yeah so the financial aspect
obviously is important but again
what's important to note here is that
your mom struggled with your dad and
obviously they ended it together and
that's a big deal
as in your mom passed but it was still
together yeah and that's a beautiful
thing yeah we were saying that more i'm
just not sure they were happy i don't
know what does happiness mean to you
like in the context of a relationship
like because they managed to have kids
you know they stayed the relationship
together like what does happiness look
like for you
not what i saw with my mum and my dad
so then what does it look like to you
then
what would you what would make you feel
happy in a relationship
um
i think what made me happy is to feel
like i have support it's feel like i
have
um to feel like i'm desired as well i'm
i'm i think that's really really
important i think it's you you have to
feel desired in a relationship otherwise
it's empty
and that's just my personality so
support and feeling desired that's what
happiness is to you
in a relationship
you do have to remember she has also
said like she can't have she's yeah i
can't when we're saying like the
commitment saying for the kids that like
she doesn't have that never had that in
fact i based all of my decisions on that
and i'm
forever regretful to be quite honest i
will be honest i i wish
that when i was
that when i found out
that i hadn't
told myself some of the things i told
myself to
sorry
i really wish i had i lied to myself i
did lie to myself to make myself feel
better about how that
was gonna go down and
um
and i think that
i don't think i i would have probably
um
received so much of the pain in her like
i'm agreeing with the whole premise of
yeah too many sexual partners
but i don't think virginal you know what
i mean there's somewhere in between
right i went too far the other way
because i couldn't have children
i imagine if i could have had children
i'd have been more careful i'd have been
more careful about who i picked you know
i'm not disagreeing isn't that the
important message you should be telling
girls though because like
trying to strike for this in between
like i understand your situation or
i can try and understand it but if we're
trying to create a better society yeah
and we've seen the consequences of these
actions based on the stats and how
people live
then doesn't it make sense to tell
younger girls this is the proper way to
behave to mitigate against these
feelings yeah well but at the sa at this
on the same token this is what i just
have a problem with it i i think there's
and okay so we can all say it starts
with mothers right we can we can all say
you know mothers teach the boys how to
act as well but i think if you're going
to say girls need to in the name of
feminism destroying marriages we also
need to be teaching men how to be men
and i just don't think that's happening
yeah because we need we need men to be
in relationships but if women are
leaving the men where's the man going to
teach the son because we live in a
society that's become more organocentric
it's more female-led which means that
most men as you mentioned are becoming
more feminine most men aren't leaders
and that's a consequence of the
breakdown of the nuclear home so if we
want to fix a nuclear home we need to
tell women
to stay with the men but they're not
staying with them and how they're going
to raise better men so long as it's not
a toxic environment for the children for
you if you're there with the kid like if
you're there with the partner you know
there is situations where like i you
know
my mom sorry like i grew up and saw my
mum beaten like that was not good for me
and that is why i am the way i am
because i refuse point blank i'm like
absolutely not not dealing with it do
you know what i mean so in those
situations i do not think it's good
but i do think it is you know if there's
a stable relationship then every child
needs that yeah well and i i agree i
don't think someone should stay through
abuse but like to me that that's the
exception it's not the rule yeah i don't
think i don't think the majority of men
are out here abusing women but a lot of
times that's that's the narrative that i
hear from the media is that men are the
problem men are men are trash men are
abusive men cheat all the time when it's
just not it's not true the numbers don't
support it i think women are the problem
and not in a horrible way i'm not you
know going against women but i do think
we
oh sorry i do think us as women like you
say we are the ones doing the choosing
and we consistently choose the same
thing over and over and over and over
again like i'm good with it myself like
i do all the time my mum will literally
look at me like what you knew what you
were going into why have you done it and
it's like we have to change our way of
thinking
but wouldn't the solution be to get
families back involved in the vetting
process
in some respects yeah i mean i would
quite happily have my nan tell me who
she thinks i have marathi why you're not
why not
because my mom clearly didn't make a
very good choice in my eyes okay and in
that you know i grew up and i didn't
think she made a good choice but my nan
you know she's very very happy why
wouldn't you have a man tell you
my granddad but my granddad's passed
okay
but i would have i would have taken
advice from him yeah
okay
um
are you okay
okay okay
okay so i wanted to read a stat so um
did you know 50 of women over 30 are
single and childless
and the number of americans who say
they've taken an antidepressant over the
past month rose by 65 percent females
are twice as likely to be on
antidepressants and 50
oh and 50 of women are single and
childless do you think that
women not having families has
contributed to their unhappiness as we
see less and less families i think
majority yeah majority of women
i would say yes as well i just think
getting to that age of 30 um i don't
know i'm reaching that soon i mean i'm
in a relationship and i hear it all the
time like i'm already hearing why you're
not married yet why don't you have kids
yet what's going on
that that i hate them questions but you
get it all the time so i imagine women
being over 30 they'll probably get that
as well from family members friends
co-workers whatever yeah
oh yeah
um
i think we
well we all know that in terms of
we a lot of women are now one of the
they're chasing the i'm a single
independent strong woman etc
um and the consequence of that is the
women in their i think it's over 40 um
and successful women 45 successful queer
women over 45
um are unhappy as a consequence of it um
so really
in the context of this women need more
well we need to rethink what it is that
um they're looking to achieve because
if the narrative is being pushed that
you know be chase your career but in the
consequence of that as you ended up on
antidepressants clearly something's not
working in in in society um meg james
talks about it in in the book the
defining decade
where a lot of people seem to rethink
seem to think that thirty is a new
twenty so a lot of people pushed a lot
of their responsibilities in their
twenties into the thirties and later
ages to chase careers to chase whatever
it is that um they think is beneficial
for their well-being and then it turns
out that when they get to the age of 30
and upwards and they haven't achieved
certain things that's when the
depression starts to take place so again
we do need to do a rethinking of
what what is the most important thing
and the numbers do say that for most
people it is marriage and a family yet
that's not the narrative being pushed in
in um in in news media and social media
um a lot of our role models who in a lot
of cases are in relationships will be
actively telling women don't don't
pursue these things so i think yeah
there's definitely a problem sorry is um
the premise of that do we really think
that um
do we really think that
men also want families and children yes
yeah we do yeah
okay because again once again my ex
didn't want children
vehemently against having them didn't
like them
i
and this was the guy who i would have
spent the rest of my life with by the
way because obviously i can't have
children i don't plan to do anything
about that maybe if i'm 14 i decide you
could adopt you know i and i've thought
about that but i certainly don't want to
do it now
you know what i mean
um because i because because i've got
i'm i've got too much stuff of my i
would do the same thing i didn't with my
ex-boyfriend and not be bringing up that
child in a in the
and i think that's a bit a massive issue
with
modern relationships and and children
it's the single parent homes
well i don't think necessarily just
single parent okay but but certainly
that's an issue right but i also just
think
um people who aren't ready for kids just
in general right
um because
i mean again this does
like i'm not you know i never said that
i disagreed with the whole premise that
you know relationships are good or some
sort of partnership with someone is good
and when that partnership is good it's
better for the children i totally
totally support that you know i'm not
saying that anyone should be in a
single-parent household but um
but certainly you know when when
you know
i think there's a there's a stage isn't
there i would imagine it as someone who
can't and hasn't ever had that pull to
have a baby or pulled her whatever i
imagine that for other people there's a
stage in their young lives where
sometimes they think oh
stupidly or wouldn't it be great if we
had a baby
i don't know i just feel like that
happens i've certainly heard
you know how how
when you're younger because obviously
your decision-making yeah your
biological clock yes yes but is it just
biological or is it just young decision
making uh well because they say that
something about your decision well
you're the most you're the most fertile
when you're like i think twenty one
twenty two yeah so that's when you're
probably when they're all over the
hormones are all over the place i wanted
a kid i i really really wondered and i'd
be the first to say i had a child at 19.
that's very very very young like i think
it just depends on the person like i
really really wanted a baby i was in a
relationship i was in love first time
i'd ever been in love you know i didn't
come from a household where i was told
that i loved it my mum left me like i
said the family unit wasn't you know
fantastic so for me having a baby was
this is someone that can love me and
someone that i will love
i learned very quickly that i don't need
to have baby i've got joe i've got a
boyfriend get on fit then i felt
pregnant so for me it was like okay now
i have this baby
still in love with her dad
things happen we fell out but i think
it's important to not put everybody in a
category of being in a single parent
home like i am obviously just meeting my
daughter in the house however
her dad is very much involved so i'm not
a single parent i do not see myself as a
single parent and i think there's a lot
of families out there where the dad is
involved and people class
single person they're not well i mean
they you might not say that they're
single parent but like statistically
they still are and you still put your
kid at every statistical disadvantage
when you take the data out of the home
even if he's involved
to a to a degree
yeah if they don't have the involvement
from their father because i know plenty
of children that don't but my daughter
has a very good relationship with her
and i believe that there's probably a
lot more parents that do that don't get
them
do you think she would have preferred
that you guys not be together or
preferred to have both of you in the
house oh no gosh you would definitely
prefer her supposed to give her she's
very vocal about that yeah she's
extremely cool about it and so like
it's kind of wouldn't it be better
advice to younger women to
maybe not point out the exception but
maybe point out the rule
yeah no i agree i mean i don't i bring
her up like how i said now i view it
like i should have worked on things i
should have worked you know what i mean
and she knows that we've spoken about it
she's a big girl she's 17 like we've had
is he's still single
no he's not he's married oh okay i was
like maybe you could call him and work
it out
he's happily married
like do you tell your you tell your
daughter um
to seek out these certain situations
with a man like do you tell her
how old is she she's 17. i don't tell
her to actually go and do it now right
now she's focusing on school and of
course of course obviously but when
you're telling about men do you talk
about the nuclear family in in that
regard do you because what i find is
that um it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
like a lot of women will will have the
breakdown of the home blame the man
and then impart that same knowledge on
their daughter so the daughter grows up
thinking
she wants a stable family but
you know based on the situation all
she's learned from my mom she doesn't
really care too much about that and then
that same situation occurs in
no i i don't feel personally like i've
laid that into her i feel like i have
broke it down like it i was just as much
to blame as he was
like even though things broke down
because of certain issues
like i also had a part to play in it
it's never just one-sided okay
okay i'm gonna read super chats real
quick guys
how many people are in the chat right
now we got 2 300. guys like the video i
i don't think we had a thousand likes on
the video hit that like button a like is
free guys also if you want to be
involved in our in the chat the second
half of the show sign up for our
memberships we just turned on members
only on top of that subscribe to the
channel come on guys a subscribe is free
so i'm gonna read the super chat so zhv
2350 watching only 645 i know i was just
talking about this jc single parent also
means not married king dreams two
dollars monkey u-s-o-p-p oh boohoo
crimea river she's a professional victim
vincent
dolezyle i honestly feel sorry for the
chick in the black on the left couch
some therapy would really do her wonders
please listen and seek professional
therapy sarah martinez crying is a
woman's response to being held
accountable for their previous bad
decisions and having to be responsible
notice how she fell back on choosing
superficial happiness through hooking up
never alone forever gotta admit i'm
amazed by her honesty and openness
hard to focus on some stuff she says but
i'll be damned she let herself cry live
whoa david henley um i feel like the
stream should be titled therapy sessions
of a stripper i do hope you
i do hope you unpack
um what you are carrying in a productive
way god bless black is uh panther i
think pearl just reset malfunctioning
barbie back into factory settings
pearl's fixing one bimbo at a time since
2022. christopher miller at least you
told the truth about having too much
testosterone please be silent and listen
these people are trying to help you you
have been misled woke quill i feel i
favor emotion over evidence and logic ob
one classic remember facts don't care
about your feelings um jill wdb please
kick the grenade in black out never
alone forever yeah that was jay-z
pulling an antsy comeback back in the
day gotta admit it was cringe brett
schmidt i hope she's looking for therapy
gangu
san
perception is not reality monkey you sap
stripper you're not a feminist you're a
misandrist um notoriously breezy i could
use a girl with a little extra
testosterone in my five a side sunday
leave league team not gonna lie i need
that assertiveness on defense i know a
center back when i see one um zentian's
men don't do enough to make women feel
sexual so let me get this straight you
aren't in control of your emotions but
you're a strong independent woman how
does that work sounds like feminist
logic calendar
there was a song of the men saying i
don't want no pidgin
um
what's a pigeon that's their response to
scrubs
there was a male version oh really yeah
what's a pigeon
testosterone is not a sex drive hormone
it's actually estrogen women are
generally have a lower sex drive because
test
ratio is different than in men aaron
hook women gaining the vote in the uk in
1918 along with four million men wasn't
an economic issue it was with the
previous expansive expansions of the
franchise bringing more and people
inside the political system as well as
the fear of communism three hey wheel
great question that is why amazing that
is why it's amazing that women think a
career is better than the future the
problem is that most women are selfish
they don't believe in sacrifice for a
bigger picture jack for us so are we
going to go gloss over the constitution
constitution needing to be revised every
19 years the forefathers would not have
agreed to freeing the slaves and women
having the right to vote
angel so because the sensible woman on
the left stands up for herself is
questioning the absurd and correct steps
pearl is using she's being called
masculine wild pearl has that pretty
white privilege oh you think i'm pretty
okay um family files 20 us 20 super chat
thank you very much obi hussein look at
how being armed is working out for the
ukraine the second amendment is
basically rambo three because that's how
americans do i'm gonna refresh the super
chats really quick one second
um
okay cause i think there's a couple more
i'll be catastrophic i'm as active as i
can
be in my kid's life but it'll never be
as much of me and my ex we're still
together the notion that she is a single
mother because the dad is active is
foolishness
jonathan adams this is the problem since
since the pro this is the problem since
eve restriction open hap opinion
happiness is and identity love try jesus
he will take that pain and
perspective you have to change at 180.
okay so um
in when i was looking at what feminism
fought for one of the things was
changes in custody and divorce laws so
um
one of those being no fault divorce
do you guys know what no fault divorce
is
so it's basically um
you can get divorced for no actual
reason like you can just go and say it
was no one's fault pretty much
but the problem is that
women win
when it comes to child support the
majority of the time 80 percent of the
time
so women are incentivized to break up
the home because they can get child
support
do you think that child support should
be is neces do you think child support
is necessary in 2022
i don't think child support is even a
thing here in the uk it is it okay well
a lot of people don't file for it in i
would say my culture anyway i can only
speak about that yeah same you get 18
for one kid of a guy's income
but i don't know anyone that i mean yeah
i don't know anyone that files for it
personally no i've had a couple guys
come on because i do public interviews
um and one of them that i did was like
my body my choice his wallet his choice
and i had a bunch of guys sit down and
say they were trapped basically for for
a kid and on the show too
yeah i don't believe that yeah so do you
do you guys think that child support is
necessary
um
i mean
not really i do believe that
man and woman should financially support
a child 50 50
but i don't think say a man should pay
more okay
let's say i agree with that you agree
that you that we need it or we don't
well i i would i would say it would be
unfair to say the primary
uh
keeper of the child would have to pay a
hundred percent i think both parents
should pay an equal amount
does that mean i agree with the current
ways in which child support is
put on people no probably not
does that make sense
okay cool
i don't know i think it's a hard one i
think if you've both gone into the
situation wanting a child
and then you split then usually it
should be you know it should be split
fairly but i think in the unfortunate
event that it is proof that you know the
woman has
um
you know split a condom or whatever to
get with a man then i yeah i think you
know you should
reap what you sow should do with it on
your own
i don't think the man should be forced
to have to pay um i think should be a
decision i believe that as a man you
should pay but i don't think that the
law should force you to pay and i think
that i think that is wrong
do you guys since we have the right to
choose what to do with our bodies do
would you support men having the right
to have a financial abortion
oh yeah 100 you would support that yeah
yeah yeah
no
not if they slept with you without yeah
i just i
i didn't say my point beforehand but i
think if you've both had sex at the end
of the day you've had sex what can
happen if you have sex you can have a
child therefore you automatically have
gone into that agreement if the child is
now born you both have financial
responsibilities point-blank people so
then are you pro-life like do you not
believe in abortion
me personally it's not that i don't
believe in abortion um if someone wants
to get an abortion that's prerogative go
for it go do what you please me
personally no i don't believe but you're
you're you support people like women
having the right issues
yeah so so wouldn't you think since we
have the right to not be a mother they
should have the right not to be a father
because like if if i get pregnant by a
guy right i i can tomorrow say i don't
want to be a mom get an abortion up to
six months in but he he's stuck paying
child support for 18 years
they created avenues for women to get
out of it they didn't create them for
men but it was men really
like
you lot could have your tubes hide men
could you could have tubes tied yeah
that's permanent no no no no you
shouldn't have mercy it can be reversed
women can't like so you could actually
physically have it done and then choose
when you want to have kids then have
them undone but we have
we have an iud you could get an iud and
you're chilling
oh yeah sorry we call it okay but those
things i mean i don't know for a man
what the effects are because they don't
really do it but for a woman there's a
lot of things that happen to our bodies
when we take when we put the coil in
when we take the pill like me personally
i cannot take the pill like it it does a
lot to me inside and it
it tells me what so i just have to you
know i just don't have sex it's the best
kind of conception um but like
for a man they can get their tubes tied
and you know why is society not saying
let's tile the men's tubes and then when
you want to have a kid
they are they are if you've seen the
media around bro versus wade
they're literally telling men to get
vasectomies but they're not always
reversible and that's a pretty big risk
yeah so so what i'm saying is for the
woman we have
we have abortion that's one form of
birth control we have plan b that's
another form of birth control we have
the pill we have an iud we can get that
thingy in her arm i don't know what it's
called
yeah
we can
do adoption if we want to have the kid
and give it up for adoption but i mean
carry a significant risk the same way in
which a vasectomy would to a man right
but why was nothing developed for a man
it's what my question is actually it
actually was no it actually was
but it wasn't marketed because they
thought it wasn't gonna no i think men
wouldn't want to
most most men would would you mind when
they would you would take would take up
well i wouldn't no
i don't i don't think you're right and
also the thing is what you have to
remember is that when it comes to um who
you're going to market let's say your
pharmaceutical company you're going to
market a drug to someone right obviously
the who does the greater risk come from
women well what i'm saying is is those
drugs are not readily available for men
they don't have that option no women
because of the pharmaceutical right but
that's not men's that's not men in
general's fault that's not
that's why
happenings back in the day were run by
men okay okay but that's a small
percentage of men that's not that's not
the majority of everyday joe schmoe
that's just having sex i still think men
have weight this and listen this is the
i think this is a really big point men
who have way more problems with doctors
pills stuff like that than women do
well then you think we would have less
unplanned pregnancies on the women's
side and they take birth control but
they do take well a lot of women do take
birth control
okay
oh well all my friends do
to their own detriment i know but then
why do we have so many single parent
homes
well yeah but i think i think that's an
a that's an inevitability no no it's not
it's not an inevitability
when you have the choice to get an iud
and you have a 99.99 chance of not
getting pregnant
so so what my point my point is that
like women we have all the power when it
comes to reproduction we choose who gets
born the men have no say in this
absolutely none because at the end of
the day i can get an abortion and the
men have don't have a say that they can
put a condom on yeah they could that's
it but
okay good that's the only thing yeah i
know but you could do it you can still
do it but but here's the thing the
condom could break and the nba issued
statements saying that women are
stealing condoms yeah
okay so so what i'm saying is a guy can
do every single thing right he can do it
guys are also taking off the condom
during certain like we've literally had
it recently so broken women women can
also be on
any type of birth control and still get
pregnant yeah but that's the exception
it's not the rule it's a 99.99 percent
or nine five or
the point is that you have
legally it incentivizes women's to try
to get kids off of rich men
and there's whole reddit threads of
women trying to get pregnant by their
boyfriends telling him let me finish
there's whole thread at threads women
trying to get pregnant by their
boyfriends
and
like like why are we in a society that
allows this where men have no rights
when it comes to reproduction you were
talking about the exception to the rule
right
um i don't think
that's the rule i don't think women
by and large are going out there taking
the condos off men because they're
desperate to have babies britney renner
made a whole video teaching she was
famous off
i think i think we even though you're
saying this um so a lot why would the
nba issue a statement because if that's
what's going on to a small percentage of
men in society what is going on with the
average joe but they do allow it because
you do allow a woman to i i there was a
guy i used to see
and he's a lovely guy still friends to
this day he you know when we finished he
used to literally take it off tie it up
and take it home he he would leave with
it and i asked him one day i was like
what how comes you know he's like you
know he's like my mum taught me to take
it home oh to make sure that doesn't
happen yeah but he's actively doing
stuff and there's a lot of men that
don't actively even look at others i
know but he shouldn't have yeah but
he shouldn't have to do that
so my point is even even if you get
pregnant right
you have a right to not be a mother why
doesn't he get a right not to be a
father
so so babies babies coming you can you
can get an abortion or you can keep it
but then don't sleep with don't sleep
with her if you don't have the intention
of like don't sleep with him yeah that's
true because i could use the same
argument that pro-life people use people
i'm not saying that you're wrong about
women i'm just saying it works both ways
if you don't want to have a baby with
somebody don't sleep with them if
there's a chance that the condom's not
going to work or she's going to get
pregnant don't do it same with the woman
but don't do it
right but then shouldn't shouldn't you
then wouldn't you say you'd be pro-life
then
what because i'm saying don't do it yeah
because that's the same argument so then
don't don't sleep with him don't you
can't get an abortion i'm not saying you
deal with the consequences i'm not
saying you can't get an abortion i'm not
saying you have to deal with the
consequences but you both have a choice
everyone has a choice but except for
that always put yeah it's always put
there's there's no choice for the man
don't sleep if i know but don't sleep
with him yeah it's true so i'm saying if
if you if she's pregnant the baby's
already coming she has a choice he
doesn't why is that fair every single
pregnancy isn't a choice which is why
things like well it is true because
sometimes
everything isn't all gross are you
talking about are you talking about
grape is that what you're talking about
that's that's less than one percent of
abortions
statistics so so it's from the abortion
clinic
okay do you have a different statistic
that you brought so or is this just
based on what you feel but okay okay so
it's based off of what it's based off of
what you feel so forty percent of women
that get abortions have had two or more
abortions
so it seems like you don't know what
their abortions are from yeah
you're speaking as if it's absolute fact
you know why every single person has one
okay but you're you're speaking as if
you have any data at all what they are
holding we live in life every day
or google to tell me what is right when
i have friends and i have people and i
know a lot of women
and yeah someone can go and do public
interviews whether you have a mic or not
you speak to people every day and you
get data from them so i speak to more
people than anyone in this room i have
women
you don't think having a live show four
times a week interviewing people on the
street well i'm just saying you're
saying that everyone knows what
pregnancy is like no my choice is not no
i'm i'm saying that less than i'm saying
that less than one percent of
pregnancies are in the instances of
grape do you think the majority of men
are out here graping women is that your
opinion every single person that's been
graped wants to do a statistic yeah
yeah yeah
but here's here's just like there's
everybody
marriage doesn't want to exactly they
don't want to sit there
okay okay let's triple it let's triple
it let's triple it let's triple it it's
still only three percent even if you
tripled it i don't even think it would
be that high i don't think so but this
is all based on your feelings this is
all based on your feelings there's no
facts in it google search statistics
is that unfortunately as much as facts
play a part so do feelings emotion and
facts do actually have a hand in each
other because the thing is that is that
statistics can only tell you one side of
something feelings can also tell you
another side okay it doesn't mean one or
the other is completely correct okay so
so this is how they gather the data they
survey people at different abortion
clinics in the us this is this is a u.s
statistic and you can also look on the
uk government website too and it's
similar so if you're looking at
different countries different abortion
clinics in different states and
different countries you and it's all
saying the same thing you don't think
that indicates that maybe that's the
that's the rate
um i i i
think i think once again i think again
or is it based on how you you feel you
can't you can't study study study study
study so for example a lot of people
don't know what's happening right so for
example i know a lot of women and i've
certainly been in that position before
myself who have not actually realized
they've been raped because say great so
great oh sorry great because we
sometimes i think have you not realized
you've been great well because there's
because there's massive gray areas there
with coercion and manipulation
and i just think that the reality of it
is is that sometimes um
you know you can get pushed into a
situation which you didn't really want
to be in and i think that that can
sometimes be put i'm not saying all that
it's a nuanced conversation
we can't speak on every single
individual case but as a whole i think
there are a lot of women who might have
like right might have not said no but
not said yes not wanted it and
later if they didn't say no how how is
he supposed to know that well okay there
is one can i just say something sorry i
i have to get involved because this is
something that's happened to me so
there is a
it happened to me
and i didn't know i thought i'd got
drunk and i was just like oh it's okay i
hadn't i'd been drugged and i had no
idea right like and i woke up the next
morning thinking oh my god like i did
this and why would i do this but it's
because i'd been drugged well if you
were drugged then that's clearly great
yeah but i didn't know i didn't know at
first so i'll tell you what happened and
people probably think i'm stupid like i
said i didn't know what had happened to
me i thought i drank a lot
and that i'd put myself in this position
which is really really bad like why for
yourself decisions first time i'm
talking about this by the way
i then um
i went out with a person again
and the same thing happened the exact
same thing happened to me and obviously
this time i went and you know because i
was like how on earth did it happen
again
and i didn't know so there is instances
where you don't know you don't know
what's happened to you because a lot of
women won't go and get checked out
afterwards to make sure would you would
you would you would you would you agree
that that's the exception it's not the
rule
because i think a lot of men are doing
that man you so that your is that your
opinion on men that the majority of men
are out here graping women i think it
happens a lot i think it does happen a
lot i think a lot more women have been
great
than will ever come out because a lot
more women won't they won't say they
won't talk about it like i said i
i haven't gone and put lay down a
statement because i don't want to yeah
like i i don't want to myself and
there's a lot of women out there that
feel the same they won't they don't want
to do it so those statistics will never
show because they've never said it
do you know i'm assuming you do that um
the actual convictions that go through
for rape are incredibly great sorry
great great are incredibly low they're
incredibly low oh yeah but you don't
know if every girl that's accusing
someone is telling the truth no of
course you don't so so it it should be
difficult to convict somebody i think it
should be i think it should be difficult
in certain certain circumstances but i
mean i i saw a
television program once where they were
following police and they got to
i mean if this woman was lying
i would be shocked she was in absolute
bits and and the guy even admitted to a
raping great graveyard raping her
on tv he admitted it on tv and then he
went in he changed his statement later
he he he got let off
she was
i mean i i don't i don't i don't okay
okay i don't i don't know that
individual story
but but it's like this this narrative
that all men are graping women i i think
is harmful to men and i think we're
again we're looking at exceptions rather
than the rule i didn't know and so and
so
but even even a lot i think that's
harmful that's why we're in the place
that we are today it's so easy for a
woman to lie yeah about something like
that happening
and so that's that's why it's important
to have a really it's it needs to be
hard to convict someone look what
happened with amber heard and johnny
depp women abuse that power
i mean again i think our person my
personal opinion on that is that that's
an incredibly isolated uh no because
that's a man with money status and power
so if that happened to someone that's fa
if that if that happened to someone
that's famous what does that say about
the average man who didn't have money
status or power any way to protect
himself or defend himself right but i
think that that's one of those
relationships you were talking about
mutually abusive i don't think it was
johnny being more abusive to her or her
being more either yeah but
they interviewed all of his exes he
never hit any of them well yes
um yeah
okay but they've still been there this
was a really public trial yeah i know i
know there was but there were still
incidences during johnny depp's career
where he's been seen to be violent no
no actually that's just the narrative
they're trying to spin and they get that
this is how clearly it works because
we're laying out the facts and then
you're going off what you're feeling and
mixing in with the with the actual
reality of the situation and this is
often what happened and like this is an
argument tactic guys like it's it's
literally when when you don't have facts
numbers or statistics you bring out
extreme scenarios
when it's not the rules sorry how was i
bringing out on the street so so we were
talking about assault earlier when we
were talking about roe versus wade yeah
and so so you guys were saying it's less
than one percent of
and you guys were saying that it's more
prevalent than it is
when that's that's the extreme i just
replied to what was said you said that
no i'm talking about okay yeah i i'm
still i'm confused as to what exact
point you're bringing out okay well we
you can watch it back later no no but
but my point is that it's like we're
talking about one thing and when we talk
about one topic we go off topic because
we're bringing up extreme situations
when we're talking about in general
well my personal opinion i i i get what
you're saying but on the same token i
think that there are a lot of different
reasons
why something happens in one sphere and
so sometimes bringing up a a point from
somewhere else actually
links in to what we're talking about
that's
that's what i've learned from
my life right but i'm saying exceptions
don't make the rule
i i i think what what rule are we
talking about here i i don't think we
were talking about roe versus no no
what i mean is when you say the rule is
the rule is that women use abortion as a
form of birth control rather than
something that should be used in in an
extreme circumstance right so so again
40 of women that that have abortions
have already had two or more they don't
track the 60 to see if they have more in
the future
okay and a lot of people make it an
income and an education type of issue
but only eight percent of women below
the poverty line actually get abortions
where one out of three women over that
make over 47 thousand dollars per year
getting abortions all right okay all
right i didn't know that
okay
i'm gonna read super chats for a second
um
okay guys um
get issue camera you already know we are
trying to get ish a camera
yes we are
by the end of i don't know we'll figure
out but no because youtube pays you
month by month so but hopefully the end
of next month
we can get him a camera based on your
donations today
basically let's make it happen
trevor trevor lane girl on the left side
of the couch i want to give you a
compliment you are still better than
chesca so thank you dragon stallion one
zero zero one a woman destroyed an
entire lacrosse team claiming they
gang-graped her the men were kicked out
of school then the investigation was
done and found out she lied vincent
dolisale jr girl in the white by the guy
is completely wrong she's making a
dangerous false assumption about grape
that she cannot that she cannot back up
with facts
kaifer hunter pearl pull up black
stallions formulation about this 90 free
tope pearl you need three men four women
four one women ratio in the room
jonathan adams just because you feel
that way doesn't mean it's true
sentience but that is the most dangerous
part of feminism confronted by facts
they rebut with feelings and along with
constant changing of definitions soon
enough just bumping into women will
actually be considered grape and assault
david flores a two dollar super chat
punisher
she keeps saying i think i think i don't
think she actually does i think she
means i feel like and doesn't understand
the difference johnny b it takes two
people to make a baby both are
responsible for the creation of that
life but a man can never legally force a
woman to be a mother a woman can legally
force a man to be a father vincent
dolisale jr to the testosterone girl yes
statistics do tell you one side of
things and that's the truth not feelings
get out of your feelings and accept
reality dancing not correct male
contraception is being developed and
soon to market all previous versions for
men failed miserably one egg is easier
than a million sperms
obi-wan classic sperm theft falls under
sperm theft falls under the rule of no
reproductive rights as a man this goes
beyond abstinence it's literally no fat
fap at this point vin diesel five dollar
super chats um
actually okay i can i see the question
i'm gonna ask that in a second manny
fresh
if men in general have a duty to get
vasectomies then women have an
obligation to make sure we are all
getting sex um the almighty lord of
honesty pearl there's a baby mama that
needs a wife and you're it
uh oh black man oh okay um
okay zach allen if the roles were
reversed would women even trust a guy
that said don't worry babe i'm on the
pill rudy g no male birth control has
been approved by any pharmaceutical
companies there are some being studied
but it's not approved the almighty lord
of honesty pearl is preaching like teddy
james oh my
wendell coven there's 12 forms of
contraception pick one
dragon stallion one zero zero one a
vasectomy is only reversible thirty
percent of the time after eight years so
vasectomy is not an option lazy artist
if pearl invited the girl in the middle
and chesca on the same show i donate my
life savings
punisher do you think that a man should
still pay half if if he has no shared
custody what if he has no visitation
rights women in the in
in men's world are considered
progressive but a man and woman's world
are considered pathetic stuart taylor
modern women can't accept the reality of
life zach allen a pigeon is someone that
is always after your bread sam kashi
before men tame the world women and
children were just easy meals for beasts
if you need us to be masculine men then
leave us in peace i'll be catastrophic
i'm as active as i can be in my kids but
it'll be it's never as be as much as if
me and my ex were still together the
notion that she isn't a single mother
because the data is active is foolish
i'm gonna refresh the page really quick
and i think there's one question that
you guys had also guys like the video a
like is free there's like 2 400 of you
in here like the video like is free if
you can't super chat at least like the
video
maurice clark so we are diagnosing
ourselves saying we've been drugged but
never tested for the presence of drugs a
monkey you saw i told you all she was a
misandris fellas don't fall for it the
tears are all they do
um christopher miller i'm a veteran
accused of great by a girl in states
while i was deployed i was federally
provable that i wasn't even in the
country and she still tried almighty
acorns you proved everyone watching that
you lack critical thinking and awareness
when you fight statistics and studies
with its feelings and extreme scenarios
david henley
this is to see ish's presumable
presumably handsome mug black
what do you have to say to that ish i
appreciate you
blackest panther menus language to
explain reality women use language to
create reality doug mpa this is the
first time i've seen pearl at her limit
she's had enough of this foolishness
stay strong pearl you're speaking for us
us saying people um trevor lane how
expensive is this new camera the uk
economist pearl you're on fire today
statistics is the only way how we
understand societies 90 free topi all
the cr the women want their cake and
they want to eat it too
okay there was a question that someone
had
please ask the panel if they support
abortion solely on the woman's right
body
um
oh that's a
a good question um
do you please ask the panel if they
support abortion based solely on the
woman's rights body then how do they
feel if a woman aborted a specific race
i don't know if anyone said that they
only agree with that
no no i'm it's that's the question so
it's like do you do you support abortion
i mean i personally wouldn't do it
but um
if you want to do it do it it's your
choice yeah
yeah same yeah i think it should be your
choice yeah
yeah i do
no
so
the one thing that so they always talk
about in the u.s that planned parenthood
is
for women like that's like that's one of
the major organizations that support
women but a lot of people don't know
that it was founded by a eugenicist so
the the point of this question is that
80 of planned parenthoods are located
within walking distance of minority
communities in the u.s and the founder
of planned parenthood referred to black
people as weeds that needed to be
exterminated
and that and they're actually doing it
to this day because the black community
in the u.s has a 50 birth rate and the
black population will be double today if
it wasn't for planned parenthood which
is the number one leading provider of
abortions in the u.s
that's crazy so is that something
because on one hand it's like my body my
choice
but on the other hand they're marketing
abortions to minority communities but i
mean
that's a surely a problem with the
institution not women
the number one pro it's the number one
abortion provider in the u.s yeah the
institution planned parenthood they're a
company with power and
right
so the way that they
run their operation is the problem
not the women who seek out their help
okay what do you guys think
i just
it's a hard one because obviously that's
horrible that's awful but who is going
to look after these kids like say you
know someone's continuously popping out
children
and they're in poverty like who's who's
looking after these but remember only
eight percent of women below the poverty
line get an abortion so the majority of
abortions are women that make over forty
seven thousand dollars per year oh yeah
you did that she said that
um
like i said i think it is horrible and i
think it's awful and i you know i don't
agree with it
being purely because they're black but
again in general well it's not it's not
necessarily like anyone can go in and
get an abortion from planned parenthood
but what they did there was a project
called the n-word project in the u.s
where they specifically might market
abortions to minority communities and
they they use the language of
it's this is affecting women of color
and they'll say things specifically to
market this to minority communities and
it's it's really crazy because margaret
sanger's grandson he's the head of
planned parenthood in new york and he's
still using the same marketing language
to this day
so like
when when that's the case is that
something we should be concerned about
yeah we should definitely be concerned
about it
and if it's not if it's not a low
if it's not an issue where the kids are
going to be in poverty
well then that's different if the kids
aren't going to be in poverty then
but hold on sorry
poverty is one thing obviously that's
probably the worst
thing we could you could imagine right a
child coming into the world into right
um although i've had not necessarily why
it's probably well
well well i mean struggling for food
kind of
poverty i mean you know a starving child
is not a happy child right
but hey i watched them adverts that
unicef put out and they got children
looking happy in africa and i don't
think that they're well nourished
and they're eating as well as anyone
else here and anyone born in 2022 has a
lower or has a higher standard of living
than most people did in all of human
history again most in all of human
history the majority of people were in
poverty like people are rich today in a
historical perspective
oh yeah i know i know that yeah yeah of
course um i think i think maybe my point
got lost i i didn't mean that
being born poor is one of the worst
things i i certainly spoke to someone
the other day who said that there was
something about his family coming
together as a unit to get through
certain things which um which obviously
he was very thankful for
but
as a um
just like a like a general rule you
don't want a child coming into a place
where they weren't wanted or where they
aren't provided or cared for in the best
way possible don't you think that's on
women though to be more selective with
who we sleep with
well or maybe be careful and get on
birth control well well certainly that
that that plays a part but i mean like i
mean again it's like women control
access to sex whilst men control access
to relationships so you sleep with who
you want while we sleep with you we can
so the ultimate ultimately sex falls on
you that's why i don't i don't
completely agree with that i think
that's that's how it is so not to push
the responsibility on women that's how
it is because you sleep with who you
choose to sleep with so that means if
you get pregnant that is a consequence
or a situation i felt or conscious of
your decisions right so shouldn't you
then make better decisions about who you
sleep with or at least the people you
sleep with should be ready to be fathers
instead of
the statistic where most people who who
live a certain sense of life
like what she said i think it goes to
the other way around as well
it's it's it's if you're gonna say that
about women choosing men you also need
to be the same the other way around
don't get me wrong men need to maintain
discipline
advocate for that but like i said you're
the ones that get pregnant the majority
of the responsibility falls on you your
body changes you're the one who has
postnatal depression etc cetera
so wouldn't it make more sense to look
after your body yeah i mean
i mean i i would agree with that but
again you know
going back into the whole
life happens right and
sometimes we might know in the back of
our heads something excuse why are we
always trying to give excuses
i think well i don't think it's victim
mentality i think it's it's of course
it's always someone else's it's always
someone else's fault no but it's the
same way in which for example men say
they don't have emotions and then get
angry right what does that have to do
with it no but
right because because it feeds into the
whole thing right that
we aren't we're animals we're not always
in control of what of what our urges and
what things happen of course we are no
we're not if you're cognizant of the
situation then you can make a choice to
actively do something or not it depends
on your level of self awareness
if you if you have a certain feeling
control there you go
but i think by and large people don't
have that i'm so i'm saying so people
are making excuses and we shouldn't be
making excuses if you do something then
be responsible for your actions i think
that's the main point oh i agree with
that i definitely agree with that so the
whole point is there's always a bailout
for women when we make bad decisions
there's always something bailing us out
it's not the same for men
if they make a bad choice they're on
child support for 18 years we get a
check
or or an abortion like so in this case
we're getting bailed out because we made
poor decisions
men can also walk away like i i know
what you're saying as well but there is
instances like
i know a lot of men that just they just
walk away they don't have to be around
so they're not around well they can they
can go to jail for that and have their
assets seized yes yes they can
[Music]
majority of people
they don't know that they don't know
that yeah right but the point is that
legally there's a consequence for men
women it's not the same i don't agree
with that i don't agree with that like
you're saying it's the truth but i don't
agree with that i feel like it should be
the same i feel like if a woman pushes
that baby and doesn't want to have
anything to do with it but to all of the
man he should be able to take her to
court the same way she can i agree wait
so you would agree with the financial
abortion then
which is like like so he says when she's
pregnant that
he doesn't want to be a father and he
can just sign off right sign up he does
he doesn't owe anything to her
i think if he said that prior to her
getting pregnant no no after she's
pregnant
so the same way
i don't know because all i'm saying is
if you can take a man to court you
should be able to take a woman to court
so
i'm sorry i'm a bit confused as to what
what way we're going here because i'm
just saying like if you have a baby and
the man is going to be on we can go to
court and say you know he needs to be
involved
so i think it should be the same the
other way around if a woman has a baby
given to the man
right so but i'm talking about if a
woman doesn't want to be a mother she
can she can kill the baby or she can
have an abortion right the fetus
whatever language you want to use but
i'm saying on the other hand a man is
still on the hook for child support
like we're a woman and she can even give
up the kid for adoption too that's
that's another option too so if she
decides to keep the baby should she be
entertained entitled to his money
essentially
no i'm not saying that exactly i just
think there's it's just it depends on
each situation each situation is
different it's hard to put it all into
one thing because he might have said to
her from the get-go
you know like i don't want to have kids
if you have this kid then i don't want
to have anything to do with it yeah like
that situation then i think at that
point that's where she has the right to
choose whatever she wants
for example if he did want the baby and
now that she's pregnant i don't want the
baby yeah what then i think it's hard
because i think the men should be able
to be involved in those situations as
well what about you eddie as a man
in what sense so like you know
um man and woman come together and
they're like you know what let's have a
let's have a child right oh so it's
agreed prayer yeah but then after the
fact he he gets cold feet or whatever
and he's like i don't want i don't want
a baby anymore what then if he's agreed
to that if he's agreed to the fact of
her baby and they've gone in to make a
baby then yeah so that's basically what
she's saying
really i thought you're saying something
different
so what does this say if it's a girl i
don't i don't think you're entitled to
child support why are you entitled to
his money you can get a job
i'm not saying you're entitled to wait
but that's that's what it is child
support means you are entitled to his
money no the child is entitled right but
but the mother gets the money
yeah but see this is this is what really
pisses me off you know you get a lot of
men and they're like you know i'm not
giving you the money so you can go out
and do this and do that i know there's
women out there that do that there is
going to get their nails done they won't
buy for their kids they won't do for
their kids and i get that 100 then there
was also a lot of mothers that all of
that money goes into their children but
then don't you think you should be more
selective with who you sleep with like
again it's it's absolving women of
responsibility so that you picked the
guy if you wouldn't make a good father
you should have been sleeping with him
no it's but like i said he works both
ways like when a man's like this woman's
trash she's taking she's not letting me
see my child you should have thought
about that before you got pregnant do
you know what i mean it does work both
ways and also but also the the only
other one thing i think like
well the courts should be even they
should be and right now they heavily
favor women over men you know i agree
with you but i don't agree but i can't
change them do you know but but i'm
saying like why don't we just get the
government out of child support like why
don't we just not have it so nobody's
entitled to anyone's money and we're all
just responsible for the decisions we
make
men and women i think a lot of more
people just walk away yeah a lot of
probably have a lot more people not get
pregnant because they know that there's
no financial backings or consequences of
that pregnancy i don't know a lot more
people make better decisions but i mean
what's the statistics on women only
getting pregnant just for money what are
the statistics on that like do you have
statistics from that because oh god how
would you get that but that's what i
mean how would you know because a lot of
women don't just do it for that i mean i
i think when you're having the nba issue
reports to all of the players that was
exactly right no but i'm saying i'm
saying okay
if that's that's a whole group of men
that it's happening to and that's the
number one way nba players go broke so
i'm saying if it's happening to the top
top top men how many men is this
happening to you yeah and i'm saying
probably less than at the top because
the top you're right it's probably less
than at the top but the point is that
shouldn't be legal to begin with which
is why i advocate for getting rid of
child support these men because all this
money should also be a lot more careful
with who they lay down with but the but
we're going back to women are stealing
their condoms that's very good
that's not the majority yeah i don't
think that's the majority then why is
the nba issuing a statement warning it's
a
player
mba is a very safe they have a lot of no
no i i think that that is common amongst
men of that status and income but they
allow the women in these men go out and
they prey on these young girls
sorry maybe not pray but but no in a
sense they can because you can go to a
club you're an nba player you know you
can have any female in there that you
want they are throwing themselves again
but that's not praying maybe not praying
all right sorry i say get back wrong
choice of words they can go out and they
can have any woman they want they will
choose these women that are all up on
their thing they're taking their free
drink they're going at you know what i
mean they take they're using their money
there and then in front of them they
know what these women are about they're
then taking them back to hotels and
sleeping with them
at that point i'm not saying it gives
them the right to steal the condom but
you've brought her back you've brought
this woman back
can i make a point can i make a point
he's doing everything right but can i
make a man a man's allowed to sleep
around if he's if he's in the top wait
if he's in the top one percent of men
he's allowed to sleep around why would i
sleep around but if you don't want to
steal you can't if you don't want to
steal the condom like be careful be more
selective with who you're taking yeah
but holding you it's weird because it's
for both i'm not saying it's just men
it's women and men everyone should be
more celebrated no but i'm
like then you would get rid of abortion
for women be more selective with who you
sleep with you could say the same thing
but like i said but like everyone said
abortion is not always that
sometimes take out take out the one
percent take out the take don't talk
about the exception we're talking about
the rule if okay well
we were talking about how you talk about
the nba players right now this is the
one instance in which men are at the at
the um
level let's say to be picking their
women
in these situations we're talking about
here it's the men because they have the
status and the power picking their women
therefore
you can say that women overall pick
their men
when the man doesn't have a huge amount
of status and power but when he has
status and power he picks well you get
you also get predatory women
yeah but predatory women practically men
are two different things kind of two
different beasts and men men
as much as we as the women
so what's the difference the different
the difference is the the general
strength and power that men over have
over women it's you know we can say men
abuse women fine but
women die at a much higher rate under
the hands of men than men do under women
even if the statistics aren't completely
correct which i would agree with
there's still a huge disparity
something like something like already
this year 60 women killed by their
husbands and
sons in domestic abuse
scenarios where where there's been like
three men three the other way around
well
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime so men are killed by men
too no that's fair to say but we're
talking about men and women we're
talking about the men and women
relationships we're not talking about
men or men violence i thought we were
talking about predatory men but it's not
the majority of men
okay so did you have something you want
yeah i just want to take it back a step
because eddie you touched a lot on um
women choose who they
sleep with and all of that so when we're
talking about the one percent the men
that do the choosing let's say the men
with the highest status you're saying
they still don't choose no they choose
that they choose at a higher rate
but they still it's not all women don't
sleep with them i'm just going to go
back because
i don't have any
i don't know examples of here in the uk
so let's go back to the u.s right in the
u.s there's i don't know um what they're
actually called but there's this podcast
and there's about three girls four girls
don't know their names one of them was
going on about how she literally let the
whole football team basketball team run
training
exactly everyone knows what we're
talking about
please note that high status men are
still sleeping with these women when you
know what they're about when you know
what they're after you're still going
there
so but we could say the same thing like
you're still sleeping with men when you
know what they're about you know they
would be bad fathers but you're still
going there a hundred percent so
no but i'm saying but but there's a fail
safe for women that's the whole point is
that women get bailed out men don't
that's why the number one reason why nba
players go broke is they get the wrong
girl pregnant so there's a there's a
there's a safeguard for women if i make
a bad decision i can go get an abortion
or i can have the kid get on child
support or i can have the kid and give
it up for adoption but men don't get
that same
out plus in that example you don't think
that those women
they're actively seeking out nba players
they said it themselves that they they
[ __ ] the whole team that's what she
was looking for
so don't get me wrong there's there's
always an element of responsibility and
that's why i say men need to maintain
discipline what men are men men are dogs
like
if they see her how they're going to put
their willy in it so if these girls are
actively seeking out these men
and still the women kind of putting it
on these men because like again
even men at the top women still turn
them down they just have a higher
success rate but women still turn them
down so it's still a similar thing
um
yeah they do but then they still take
home the ratchet ones
and that ratchet one's going to be the
one that's going to steal your condom
i don't know if that's the same
situation though
the whole point is there's a failsafe
women get out of everything men don't
but
what do you suggest that we do for men
what do you use
i did i just suggested it a financial
abortion and that's the only thing
there's nothing else i think that that i
would say that would alleviate a lot of
problems i'd also like to see um should
child support be 50 50 or not child
support sorry custody be 50 50 where
just automatically no matter what unless
there was abuse 50 custody for the man
and the woman i agreed it wouldn't need
to be child support if custody was 50
50. can i add to that so if you're
saying that you agree with men having
financial abortion you give you say oh
financially i'm abortion so then do you
agree with the women with the woman
going to also have an abortion or no
no that's what we're saying so if
they're able to do that then men should
also be able to have financial abortion
so do the men see these kids so the men
that have a financial abortion is it is
it because they don't want anything to
do with this child they don't want to
see the child or the financial abortion
isn't actually a thing it's more of a
scenario like if if women are if it's my
body my choice they should be like my
money my choice yeah but i'm just saying
like but you know i mean i'd get that if
you like you said if everyone had 50 50
and then you're taking the child and you
know you're caring for the child and
you're buying the child clothes and
doing your thing then i there would be
no need for childbirth 100
100
but they're not going to do that are
they
in the ideal world
[Laughter]
would you you would agree with the 50 50
though 100 we do agree yeah 100 yeah
because it's not it's not fair that the
women just get it because they're women
it doesn't automatically mean they're
good
i i agree like i've seen some men that
look after their kids and the women
still claim the child support and all
the you know like the tax credits and
whatever and they don't even have these
children and like one of my friends he
has sole custody of his daughter
and the woman was still taking well
actually i'll tell you how it's set up
in the us it's actually really crazy
because so let's say i'm with a guy
right it doesn't work out and he leaves
because we're just fighting too much i
can
legally keep my kids away from the dad
for months and then go to court and say
the dad's not in their life yeah and and
this has happened there was a guy who
did a youtube video on it and the wife
literally took his kids to to japan
and so on top of that i'm also per kid
i'm entitled to 25 of his income
so and that's after taxes so your
recreation if i bring home two thousand
if he brings home two thousand dollars a
month i could if i had two kids by him
i'd be i'd get a thousand
and the crazy thing is men will spend
twenty thirty thousand dollars fighting
in court to get their kids back and
they'll be financially ruined because on
top of that even if he loses his job i'm
still entitled to the money he had from
his old job that's why nba players go
broke because they have multi-million
dollar contracts they get into these
child support agreements and they're not
re-signed so they lose all the money to
to a girl and so right now it's just
we're in a place in society where women
have all the power and men have none
and i just don't think it's right i i i
i don't i don't disagree that there are
imbalances in power but i think to say
that women have all the power
reproductively yes
when it comes to we're in control of
birth
i i think i think i think
you're still just leaving out some
really big points that like manipulation
coercion all of those things even even
even if that happens you can still
legally have an abortion so we are in
control of birth
[Music]
i i i think you say we are in control of
birth but i think there are a lot of
women who go through with pregnancies
because
and they're in a relationship where the
husband wouldn't allow it
well i know but they can still give it
up for adoption there's actually a case
in the u.s where the the guy or the
woman gave the kid up for adoption even
though the dad wanted to be wanted the
child so he had no legal rights to the
kid and it took him years to get the kid
back well that's obviously disgraceful
yeah and that should never happen but
that's that's the whole point is that
like we're
we are in control of birth we have a
hundred percent reproductive power um
i don't think it's it's never a hundred
percent though nothing in life is a
hundred percent okay if i said ninety
nine point nine five well no
no no because no because i think it's
probably like way less that is way less
than that
the thing is is that you're saying a
hundred percent but there is actually no
data okay support okay 100 percent so
let's see even with all the data we're
in school
yes there is okay we're in the uk
if you get pregnant you want to get an
abortion can you
yes but that doesn't that's okay okay so
so
if you if you got pregnant or eddie if
you got a girl pregnant and you wanted
her to get an abortion could you make
her no if you got a girl pregnant and
you wanted her to keep it could you make
her nope
i'm sorry just because you say no
doesn't mean that there aren't men out
there who can definitely definitely
uh
force their wives into into a decision
they don't want to do including getting
rid of it but you're going to extremes
again and again i'm going through the
streams
okay even even exactly things that
happen in a relationship in
relationships all the time okay i'll
give another example
one of the big topics as well around
this is consent yeah if you look at mark
and
gladwell's book um talking to strangers
he said that the legal system and he was
making a point of how the legal system
is geared towards women again the
society being ganner century when he did
the study it turns out that men and
women equally don't know what consent is
but if you go if you take that child to
court the man's the one that gets
convicted so the example he used was a
kid in the university these two are both
drunk they slept with each other she
woke up feeling like a hoe so she then
went to report to the police and they
end up losing this place at university
as a consequence of them both being
drunk equally drunk and not knowing what
consent is so how can you then argue
that the reverse is
it's not consistent at all who gave
women all these powers
was it women or men like do we no
because i don't i hands up i haven't got
a clue like who gave women which all
these rights the abortion it's you know
your choice the fact that you get more
support when it comes to having the
child i do think you know like back in
the day is you were seen as you're a
woman you look after child that's your
responsibility so was it a woman that's
given these powers to
the women or was it a man that actually
give these powers in the u.s margaret
sanger was a big part of that like that
that was her
yeah yeah so
you don't know yeah mark i don't know in
the uk off the top of my head um i know
that you guys got free abortions about
five years ago like in the last five
years abortions became free so they're
government funded now um in the u.s
it was margaret sanger she
was a big proponent of proponent of
pushing birth control and abortions and
that was the eugenicist that we talked
about earlier
okay um
actually the
i think that we're gonna wrap up the
show
um why don't you guys we're gonna do a
final round of super chats but why don't
you guys go around um say any final
thoughts you have and where the people
can find you
and i'll start
so my mind has changed and i actually
agree with financial abortion just say
it
let's go
i'm just saying so long as um you know
the woman can still do her thing as well
she then has the ultimate decision of
what she wants to do after a financial
abortion decision is made okay
um yeah i mean
i've always kind of agreed with the
whole um financial abortion i feel like
if you don't want the child then you
shouldn't be forced
to um fund the child um
providing that you never wanted it from
the get-go
yeah
um i mean i mean
look i i always thought financial
abortion was fine but in
circumstances once again you have to
look at the case-to-case scenario you
can't just say well you know anyone
could just do what they want and i think
that feeds into the
abortion argument too
you know what i mean um
so
my thoughts are sorry
um you know i i do agree with it but i
also agree with the whole 50 50 so long
as you know the
mum and dad have equal amount of time
then the financial abortion is fine and
yeah my chance to angelina on instagram
um
wait i think
yeah feminism is a problem for long-term
relationships i need to i think we need
to rethink what new feminism is you need
feminism but
that is always that
that is what feminism is today is
right
it's breaking up nuclear families and i
think there needs to be more
responsibility on on the female side
just based off the statistics i don't
want to say it's all females faults but
based on the statistics and what we see
um there's common trends between higher
levels of promiscuity long-term
relationships the breakdown of nuclear
families but single-parent homes are the
consequences that follow in society so i
think we all need to be very cognizant
of um these issues that are taking place
and act accordingly
okay guys i'm gonna read the last super
chat do you do you wanna
okay i don't know if you want to have
any final thoughts you wanted to
we got it we got a girl in the
background if you have any final
thoughts go in the background i just
think everything isn't as black and
white as it's been made out to be every
single situation isn't like
you chose this and you chose it on both
sides i'm not saying men and women but
everyone needs to
be aware of the consequences of the
things that happen
and
aware of the world we live in like
you can get the normal abortion
you can't get a financial abortion but i
get it but if we can get a normal
abortion you should be able to but as
maddie said it's
what's it consequent
what's the word dependent on your
situation each situation yes it depends
on your situation okay so i'm gonna read
super chats um thank you guys so much
for all the donations they're going
towards ish's camera i promise you guys
next month we're trying to see what ish
looks like oh sure
i got a question before you yeah go
ahead um to all the ladies
if you
find a man that you deem the highest
valuable man that you can
keep
would you
if you
then get pregnant by him
would you be okay with him having a
financial abortion
[Music]
that's a good question
that's a great that's a very good
question i'll go around the room
yes
straight face gang
why is he having a financial abortion
because he doesn't want the kid no one
do you oh that but that means he don't
want me as well cool that's fine no but
you want him yeah but he don't want me
so so you've deemed him the [ __ ] highest
valuable man that you can attain like
he's doing better you ain't doing better
he's the yeah but he still don't want me
okay you don't want to have a kid with
me he don't want me so
that that's not going very far okay fair
enough
i would say the same thing to be honest
okay
um
i'm under the assumption that this
relationship bearing in mind he's the
person that the woman's put on a
pedestal is a good one and one that they
both thought that they could have kids
together so why is he now pulling out no
you're under the assumption that
he is the highest valuable man that you
believe you can attain and keep right
i'm not necessarily saying you're
together right i'm just saying oh okay
you deem him right the pinnacle of what
you could do right best but that would
be assuming that i would get pregnant by
him and one of which i would never even
if i could have kids in an ideal
scenario okay i like not i'll do sorry i
would never i would never do anything to
keep a man ever if he wants to be there
well no
on a basic level on a human human level
yes but not on a to do anything to have
him here even if he doesn't want to be
yeah
we ain't tying up condoms yeah yeah
me
yeah no i i wouldn't be with him
whether he's the highest standing
man ever if we discussed previously you
didn't want to have kids because you
know it's not something you wanted then
cool and if i didn't want him fine but
if i would have childhood yeah like you
said you don't want me either so
all right you wanna answer as well
um if you got pregnant by him
you wanted to keep the kid because you
deem him to be like
the pinnacle of what you could get in
life would you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
would you keep the kid
um knowing for he wants a financial
abortion
my son's dad is a waste man and i still
kept the kid knowing that he ain't the
highest pinnacle man so it's not about
these guys out here
women want to raise their babies some
men do as well or they don't
man ain't gonna dictate that for me
okay so you'd support the financial
abortion as long as women can have a
yeah okay okay
okay chase chase chase conley both can
be true it's wild that a simple question
can't be just be answered without hoops
of fire to jump through lazy artist ask
the girl in the middle who sent you was
it cheska
they love jessica
um christian christian forte the woman
needs therapy her body language screams
mental baggage ritual richard harrington
the chick is just making excuses to act
like she won richard harrington speaking
as a single father with 90 10 custody of
my daughter i'm still paying child
support to her mom for the five days a
month she has her in california dragon
stallion one zero zero one quit saying
manipulation and coercion when the truth
is you regretted it after you did the
dirty ob one classic proposition child
support is treated like donations are
like donations and are tax deductible
thoughts the courts would never do it
but still michael the nba isn't the only
league it's happening to true in the nfl
rugby mlb it's most men with money in
general this happens the black is
panther these women talking is exactly
why i treat women like children until
they prove otherwise grown women have
less accountability than actual children
notoriously breezy just clocked why the
light-skinned one is single wendell cove
and pearl this is why women die alone
cinar stinks there are male and female
condoms this is not an excuse 20 anymore
it's 2022 her body her choice her
responsibility women are the guardians
of their temple the uk economist so how
are women in upper upper middle and
upper classes able to pick decent and
stable men to build families with is
this a class issue girl in the back has
gone too far cut the losses and move on
um good mother great title and thumbnail
pearly keep up the great work feminists
need that more women holding them
accountable senior stinks planned
parenthood is population control also
the fact that no one cares about the
kids
if they did if they're they if they did
there would be no orphanages period elk
male contraception you're actively
taking away the control from a woman
women get pregnant therefore the
contraception burden is heavier on women
david henley by the way no homo on the
ish handsome camera content i'm open for
business ladies 90 free toe pay yes or
no pearl do they support abortion if
they found out the woman was aborting a
specific race richard harrington i just
want to say i appreciate you and
everyone of the same people you bring on
much love to you all senior stinks
feminists ruined by marriage by taking
away the carrot black is panther the
only time a woman cries or genuine is
when she's crying in private kendall
scott so much hate geez just listen and
let someone else speak pearl you have a
patience of a saint maurice clark
so we are diagnosing ourselves saying
we've been drugged we've been never been
protested for the presence of drugs
monkey usp um
i told
okay i think i did the all of them was
there any well i was reading ish
okay okay i'll do i'll do a couple more
90 free tope they can't answer one
question chase conley both can be true
this is wild that a simple question
can't just be answered without hoops of
fire to jump through okay that's all of
them
okay guys um thank you so much for
watching tonight as you guys know
i appreciate every single one of you
please like the video on your way out a
like is free subscribe to the channel
join our memberships also follow our
facebook page and our new twitch page
they're brand new so we're trying to get
some traction on those pages and dm
eddie if you want to come on the show
and you do live in london
don't forget to subscribe on your way
out i'll talk to you next time bye